une vocation la politique chez vous
[Musique]
si je me retourne vous savez camus qui
dit ça on se retourne devant ce fouillis
de fait et on appelle ça un destin on
est toujours là
mais je me suis engagé politiquement tôt
puis j'ai entendu parler de politique
très tôt parce que
j'ai mon âge comme vous le savez j'ai 67
ans et donc j'étais un petit garçon
pendant la fin de la guerre d'algérie et
mes parents
mes grands parents et arrière grands
parents sont pieds noirs
les uns d'oran les eaux d'alger moi je
suis né au maroc et donc
la guerre en algérie était un sujet
quotidien et vous en entendez parler
avec eux vous êtes petit tout ça vous
marque
donc je savais ce qu'était la politique
elle étaient les
les implications les conséquences j'ai
toujours su que la politique c'est un
sujet tragique
que c'est de l'histoire en mouvement
donc il m'arrive des fois d'être un peu
dépaysé avec les gens pour qui d'entrée
de jeu c'était une carrière
c'était pas du tout comme ça quand le
figuraient du temps j'étais jeune
militant quand je me suis engagé
trotskiste d'abord puis socialiste à
l'époque du programme commun personne ne
voyait la politique comme ça enfin
peut-être qu'il y en avait un moi je les
connaissais pas
et c'est devenu ensuite une chose
beaucoup plus banal mais peut-être
qu'elle était aussi avant je ne savais
pas que de faire les grandes écoles et à
la sortie des grandes l'école choisir en
partie et essayer d'y faire carrière
donc quand vous me dites une vocation a
l'impression qu'on est appelée de
l'extérieur moi j'ai été appelé du
dedans parce que mes premières émotions
politique c'est le bruit de fond de la
guerre d'algérie à laquelle évidemment
un gamin de noeuds dix ans comprend pas
grand chose mais c'était l'indépendance
du maroc
et la vision de la souffrance de la
pauvreté et maintenant la parole est
plus libre sur le sujet disons qu'à
l'époque la souffrance des animaux me
frappait et me touchait autant que celle
des personnes parce qu'il me semblait
qu'elle était encore plus ils étaient
encore plus démunis puisque pouvait même
pas parler pour protester bon voila
voila l'environnement mais les gens que
j'ai connus ensuite j'ai observé que
nous avons eu souvent les mêmes parcours
c'est à dire une des indignations
d'enfants ou de jeunes hommes ou de
jeune femme est ensuite des
circonstances qui vous met aux prises
avec des événements qui vous dépasse moi
j'ai eu de la chance toute ma vie j'ai
été aux prises avec des événements qui
m'ont rappelé que en histoire et
histoires et 2 qu'elle est tragique
quand vous avez la chance à 16 ans
d'organiser votre adolescent sa rupture
avec l'autorité paternelle et qu'en même
temps c'est les événements de
1968 où vous rompez que la figure
paternelle du général de gaulle c'est ça
crépite à c'est le quai ce que c'est le
petit triangle rouge que je vois là le
triangle rouge c'est un
c'est un symbole
qui m'a été offert par des syndicalistes
belges
un jour où j'étais particulièrement
triste parce que ce pauvre type de
plantu avait fait un dessin où ils me
mettaient sur le même plan que madame le
pen
et alors j'avais un brassard comme un
comme un nazi et c'était tellement
contraire de mes convictions que j'avais
été blessé assez profondément ce qui tue
qui est ridicule plantu n'a aucune
espèce d'importance est un clown
pitoyable ans gars qui est capable
d'accepter 10000 euros pour un prix la
liberté de la presse du qatar mais
mérite que notre mépris mais à l'époque
je le prenais au sérieux parce que je
l'aimé bien j'aime bien ce qui est
dessiné c'est après j'ai compris
m'offrir ce jour là ça allait mal quoi
j'avais vraiment le moral dans les
chaussettes et je raconte mon histoire
un gala cgt de belges que ça fait rire
bio tu te fais bien du souci pour rien
diatta km ça comme ça ils se
rappelleront alors ça c'est l'insigne
des déportés communistes socialistes
syndicaliste
quand la wehrmacht ou le lait c'est sous
la gestapo arrêtés l'un des nôtres et
qu'il les déportés encore il leur coller
des triangle rouge nous n'était triangle
rouge
les droits comme un triangle noir les
homosexuels triangle rose
on en avait ça et alors je les mii
et ensuite j'ai réalisé que avant moi un
autre la porte le portait régulièrement
qui est olivier besancenot donc pour moi
c'était une garantie de sérieux
et puis
ensuite je me suis fait raconter
l'histoire il paraît qu'au 1er 1er mai
français
les ouvriers parisiens avaient mis en
triangle en cuir rouge
parce que c'était le 1er mai est né
comme sur la base d'un moteur de
l'internationale socialiste c'était la
seule qui avait à l'époque la première
internationale
pour la journée de huit heures alors on
disait huit heures de travail huit
heures de loisirs 8 heures de repos
voilà c'est comme ça qu'est né le
triangle rouge et la tradition de le
porter quand on vous object des trains
rouges bruns ça vous fait quel effet bas
au début c'est blessant puis après on
s'en fout parce que comme ça on va déjà
qualifié d'à peu près tout
c'est je sais pas qui me qualifie de
rouge blanc il y en a d'autres qui me
qualifie de
de tout j'ai eu droit à peu près tout et
si possible des choses dont je ne
pouvais pas me défendre par exemple
pendant près de huit jours la presse a
fait un numéro
après qu'il ya eu des tags dans paris
avec des croix gammées tous les gilets
jaunes ont été taxés d'être des
antisémites et ceux qui soutenaient les
gilets jaunes dans être aussi où ce qui
était pire comme formule d'être ambiguë
alors si vous avez une accusation dit
vous êtes antisémites parce que vous
avez dit si ou ça vous pouvez vous
défendre ou accepter mais quand on vous
dit juste d'être ambigu c'est juste fait
pour vous humilier pour vous blesser et
vous interdire de répondre parce que
qu'est ce que voulait répondre à une
accusation pareil donc le rouge brun
c'est pareil ça veut dire quoi qu'est ce
qu'on me reproche sur quel sujet donc
les étiquettes je me contrefous parce
que je n'ai aucun respect pour ceux qui
me les attributs dans la période récente
c'était dictateur
alors évidemment on trouve toujours
un courtisan déçu quelqu'un qui a été
mal placé dans une liste pour dire c'est
un scandale moi qui mérite d'être ceci
ou cela je n'y suis pas donc c'est la
faute du dictateur mois on a beau
expliquer sur tous les tons que c'est
pas moi qui fais la liste mais un comité
très haut ça je pourrais sortir mon
téléphone et montrer que ceux qui
m'accusent d'être en dictateurs sont
précisément ceux qui m'ont les lécher
les pieds avec le plus d'énergie pour
obtenir tel ou tel le faveur de ma part
mais il n'y en a pas il n'y en aura pas
il n'y en aura jamais genou coup part
mais j'ai mis du temps je n'ai pas quoi
répondre dictateur qu'est ce que ça veut
dire alors oui voilà ma réponse donnez
moi un exemple d'une décision que j'ai
pris tout seul et qui vous paraissent
brutale ou inappropriés ou n'ayant rien
à voir avec les canons notre
organisation je pense qu'il faut
apprendre à vivre sous les insultes ce
qui a été le plus dur pour moi c'est
d'être capable de cultiver en moi antero
d'indifférence
parce que toute ma vie c'est un
engagement et s'habituer à devenir un
différend ça va contre votre culture
profonde de militants de même que la
meilleure technique en média s'est pas
répondre à une attaque c'est le
contraire de ce qu'on apprend à faire
dans la vie militante ou les coûts
bref les petites présentations gentiment
on va aborder des sujets comme la
géopolitique la finance le terrorisme le
hacking voulait commencer par quoi comme
vous voulez c'est tous des sujets le
hacking est certainement celui je
connais le plus mal commencer par
sculptée pour mieux dire que je n'y
connais rien et allongez vous connaissez
rien du tout à quillan si vous demandez
la souveraineté des données des français
ça vous parle ça vous parle pas les gars
fassent ça vous parle oui
tout la kings consiste à rentrer dans un
système soit pour le pirater soit pour
le détourner le hacking c'est comprendre
un système le démonter leur montée pour
peut-être l'améliorer ou à la patrouille
avait envoyé c'était je faisais un
contresens je croyais que c'était un
acte de agressif ou de piratage il faut
faire la différence entre pirates et
acura
façon les pirates ne sais pas pour moi
dans ma bouche et pas forcément
connoté négativement
si je me réfère aux pirates initiaux qui
comme la première société socialiste
égalité les pirates n'est ce pas avec un
système de sécurité sociale interne les
élections et toucha donc pour moi c'est
pas un mot négatif
quand on dit la russie a que les états
unis ac les français ac ça vous pas vous
avez des
affaires en tête ça vous fait parler à
quoi ça vous fait blanc j'ai une idée en
tête c'est que je crois que l'armée
française doit disposer de
deux comptes argent pour la guerre pour
cette guerre la connaissez babar je suis
pour nom je suis pour que l'on soit les
meilleurs
on verra sur la quille un peu plus tard
bah oui mais ça une importance actuelle
c'est la question de du niveau auquel
vont se porter les prochaines guerres et
les prochaines confrontations
il établit un certain est-ce qu'on est
en guerre
sur le plan juridique non parce qu'il
paraît qu'on doit cela déclarait avant
la guerre d'accord sauf comme vous
l'avez perdu tellement vite que bon vous
n'avez pas le temps de recevoir la
déclaration de guerre mais clairement le
monde est sous tension et la course aux
armements de nouvelle génération est
très avancé pour une bonne partie elle a
lieu dans l'espace
il est vraisemblable que c'est depuis
l'espace qui auront lieu les prochains
assaut décisif et que tout le matériel
qu'on utilise interconnecté sera à peu
près aussi utile que je sais pas moi un
fer à repasser pour son chaleur pour se
coiffer
donc je sais que les états unis
d'amérique
les chinois les russes sont capables
d'éclairer depuis la terre satellite
c'est à dire de le faire éclater alors
passons sur les dégâts verdien les
indiens aussi des indiens aussi qui est
possible et nous aussi peut-être
mais nous on doit pas être une en
arrière je suis pour la démilitarisation
absolue de l'espace pas si ça a un
rapport avec notre sujet mais je crois
que ça en a 1 parce que vous êtes vite
passé de la connaissance des systèmes la
capacité d'entrer en eux pour les
remonter ou les détourner
et moi je suis venu sur la guerre parce
que je pense que c'est un des sujets un
des domaines de confrontation auquel
l'esprit public et le moins préparés
dans notre pays je ne sais pas quel est
le niveau de préparation et de
compréhension des états majors sur le
sujet
parce que ce n'est pas moi qui traite ça
directement mais bastien lachaud qui est
membre de la commission de la défense
et qui a présenté notre contribution
quand le débat est venu sur la loi de
programmation militaire jeu ça peut vous
paraître étrange que des gens comme nous
s'intéresse à samedan s'y intéresse
beaucoup c'est pas nouveau dans notre
famille intellectuelle je rappelle que
jaurès a écrit l'armée nouvelle
moi je suis attaché au principe
d'indépendance de souveraineté
pour moi c'est la même chose
parce que l'indépendance souvent dit
l'indépendance nationale mais qu'est ce
qu'on entend par nation dans ma bouche
nation égale peuple souverain
comme je dis patrie la moitié du temps
parce que des fois j'oublie les gens
gueulent ceux qui oublient jeudi la
patrie républicaine pour moi ça n'a pas
de sens la france autre chose que
républicaine par conséquent la
souveraineté et la souveraineté
populaire pour qu'elle puisse exercer il
faut qu'elle soit libre l'indépendance
et la condition d'un des plus de la
souveraineté populaire est ce qu'on est
libre là est ce qu'on est indépendant
est ce que le quai d'orsay n'ont ni les
moyens des pareils est ce que quand on
fait des traités pas des traités mais
quand on vend de l'armement à l'arabie
saoudite quand l'arabie saoudite
utilisent cet armement y est belle qui
s'attendaient attendait la première
question c'est est ce qu'on est libre et
indépendant libre non et je le dis sans
sans exagération monsieur jo parce que
monsieur junqueira dit il n'ya pas de
démocratie possible en dehors des
traités européens
d'accord donc nous ne sommes pas libres
puisque on ne peut pas aller au delà des
traités mais précisément le sujet qui
nous occupe en politique qui nous
enferment qui limite la souveraineté
populaire ce sont les traités européens
puisqu'ils l'institut qu' on ne peut pas
faire d'harmonisation fiscale on peut
pas faire d'harmonisation sociale on
doit organiser la concurrence libre et
non faussée dans tous les domaines etc
etc donc les traités sont un carcan ne
vont pas le droit d'en sortir ceux qui
essayent d'en sortir sont frappés avec
une dureté total par des actes de guerre
comme ce fut le cas lorsque on prive à
chypre de sam de tout accès à l'euro
parce qu'il n'y avait pas un député qui
a accepté le mémorandum proposé par
proposer imposée par la commission repas
ils ont pas trouvé un député même de
droit qu'il n'avait pas alors on l'a dit
si vous le prenez comme ça il ya plus
d'argent évidemment au bout d'une
semaine
le ko était garanti mais privé une
nation de l'accès à sa monnaie puisque
c'est une nation qui à l'euro pour
donner c'est un acte de guerre de la
même manière quand la grèce qui refusait
de céder a été astreinte d'abord à
seulement 120 euros par semaine qui
ensuite seulement 60 on peut dire que
l'union européenne a fait la guerre à
deux réfractaires en coupant la monnaie
par conséquent nous ne sommes pas libres
deuxièmement nous ne sommes pas
indépendants puisque nous sommes
intégrés dans un système de défense qui
a cette particularité de nous lier aux
décisions d'autres et en particulier des
états unis d'amérique qui domine et
dirige l'otan l'organisation du traité
de l'atlantique nord en français c'est
ça que je veux dire l'acronyme autant
comme vous le savez il y a des gens très
peu convaincant comme membre de
l'atlantique nord tels que les japonais
ou depuis peu les géorgiens qui n'ont
absolument aucun contact avec
l'atlantique nord j'en passe et des
meilleurs les turcs
et et que sais-je encore donc nous
sommes pris dans un système qui est
dirigé par les nord américains qui font
ce qu'ils veulent et qui impose aux
participants de leur alliance eux
d'acheter leur matériel et de le rendre
compatible c'est à dire à impose la
langue anglaise et les systèmes de
communication et d'inter opérabilité
décidées par les états unis d'amérique
ensuite arrive notre propre stupidité
à moi que ce soit très bien contrôlée
qui consiste à installer des logiciels
nord-américain dans l'hémicyle français
ou d'équipé le siège de l'armée
française de logiciels nord américain ce
qui peut être soit mis sur le compte de
la stupidité soit de la trahison la
forme et pour eux c'est pas une trahison
puisque les américains sont nos amis et
nos alliés tout va bien et en fait il
n'ya qu'à faire comme ils disent et tout
ira encore mieux d'ailleurs le mythe est
arrivé il faut dire il est très
performant maintenant comme vous faites
des sondages les français sont persuadés
que c'est les américains qui ont libéré
la france ni la résistance ni les russes
ans pourtant 20 millions de russes sont
morts et si quelqu'un nous a libérés
c'est les russes
ont fait quoi avec l'europe on sort on
fait un freak sitcom l'invoquent
françois asselineau on fait quoi je vois
qu'il ya trente quatre listes ou
trentaine de listes pour les européennes
en fait y en a que deux il ya à ce livre
qui veulent à la sortie et tous les
autres
pourquoi pas mais
disons que le tableau présenté comme ça
peut satisfaire un moment de gaieté
entre nous mais c'est pas le sujet
on fait quoi alors non attendez on fait
quoi vous êtes presque aussi
lamentable que les journalistes de
l'officialité c'est alors on sort ou en
reste alors si on reste c'est comme cela
si on sort alors c'est la ruine et la
catastrophe riber nucléaire il ya un
paramètre que tous ces gens ni qui
s'appelle asselineau ou qu'ils
s'appellent tous les autres c'est
l'existence d'une grande nation qui
s'appelle la france
d'accord nous n'avons aucune raison de
ne pas vouloir changer ce qui est parce
que personne ne peut se passer de nous
on ne fait pas l'europe sans les
français donc malines c'est sortir des
traités mais qu'on me dise oui ou comme
disent non si demain je gouverne ce pays
de toute façon j'appliquerai mon
programme
plan à on discute vous voulez pas
plomber on le fait quand même
c'est une position politique qui inclut
un paramètre qui est absent du
raisonnement des autres les aligner
c'est la france n'est rien ne compte pas
quand on vous dit mais et si vous
convainquez par les autres pardon qu'est
ce qui ne peut pas être convaincu par
les français qui nous allemands alors
par nous en parlons du rapport à
l'allemagne mais regarde traitons des
questions comme elle se pose à une
grande nation celui qui dit je sors
qu'est-ce qu'il dit dit j'ai perdu 10 la
france compte pas elle n'existe pas elle
pèse 0 c'est le gouvernement allemand et
son hinterland qui décide et wc pas mon
avis et supposons que tout ça bien n'a
éclaté ce qui est à mon avis le destin
promis de la construction actuelle puis
a déjà les anglais sont partis
personne n'a l'air de trop se demander
pourquoi ils pas on a entendu c'est
parce qu'ils n'ont pas bien compris ça
leur nous l'a fait aussi à nous pour le
non si l'on parfaitement bien compris
qu'ils n'avaient aucune raison de rester
là dedans parce que ça leur rapporte
rien ça alors ça ne leur rapportait rien
alors ça se combine avec un sentiment
national des anglais qui a toujours été
très
comment dire une affirmation très forts
de leur existence de leur nation ils ont
toujours été comme ça heureusement cela
a permis de tenir tête aux nazis tandis
que nos élites à nous ont capitulé
séance tenante bon comme comme tout le
monde le sait ou ne le sais pas a
capitulé face aux états unis la wii
alors ça c'est passé en plusieurs temps
le dernier qui a résisté à mon avis
c'était françois mitterrand
le fondateur de notre indépendance il
faut le dire c'est de gaulle avec
la dissuasion tous azimuts aujourd'hui
tout ça ça parait être du passé beaucoup
nous en rappelle même pas que ce débat
ait lieu
mais à l'époque tous azimuts général
vous n'y pensez pas comment tous azimuts
nous n'avons qu'un ennemi
dans la guerre froide sur virus elle lui
disait non c'est tout azimut un jour à
une conférence de presse un journaliste
revient là dessus alors est ce que vous
êtes toujours sur la position tous
azimuts et alors il répond il dit ovi
est dit et depuis j'ai pris cette
position je ne vois pas quelles choses
aillent plus mal bon qui était sa façon
à lui de essayer de faire baisser la
tension vis-à-vis d'un mot qui étaient
énormes qui était dire que a priori
tout le monde pouvait être un adversaire
des français s'il contrevenait à ce que
les français ont décidé et qu'ont décidé
les français qu'on ne peut pas leur
toucher un seul cheveu sens qui rendent
un coup majeur et deuxièmement que
l'europe n'est pas un théâtre
d'opérations militaires voilà pourquoi
je dis que alors ça c'est la grande
tradition là dessus est arrivé bon
différents présidents ont rien changé à
sa
et jeudi le dernier qui posait des actes
de résistance
qui sont assez forts finalement
il me semble que c'est le françois
mitterrand notamment au moment où ils
refusent
l'installation de ce qu'on a appelé les
missiles à roulettes alors ça voulait
dire qu'on est déplacé
des missiles parce que ils avaient une
portée de 450 à 500 km ce qui veut dire
que vous prenez un compas on comprenait
pour qui c'était ça ne pouvait
fonctionner qu'en europe et contre un
autre pays européen or notre position
c'est on ne se bat pas en europe et
quiconque veut se battre en europe
pourra faire à nous les français parce
que nous sommes une grande puissant
atout de la prémisse de départ c'est que
nous sommes une puissance y on considère
comme juste un petit machin là au milieu
moment n'en parlons plus mais moi je
continuerai à penser que nous sommes une
puissance est là la trahison s'est faite
en plusieurs étapes d'abord on a eu un
président qui était intimement
convaincue de l'atlantisme que sarkozy
c'était sa conviction personne ne peut
dire qu'il a été pris par surprise
je me rappelle d'un dirigeant socialiste
qui ensuite a changé de camp comme
beaucoup d'autres monsieur besson qui
avait traité sarkozy en disant sarkozy
l'américain
nicolas sarkozy adore les états unis
allaient à new york courez dans les rues
enfin bref ce qui était une attitude
inconnu des dirigeants français et puis
est arrivé pire derrière c'est françois
hollande personnage gélatineux à bord
flou et donnant toujours l'impression de
se moquer de tout et tout le monde mais
qui posait des actes et qui a commencé
le 1er à qu'il apposait après son
élection a été d'aller à la convention
de chicago de l'otan et là il a accepté
l'installation de missiles anti missiles
dont on nous disait à l'époque qu'ils
étaient destinés à contrer les missiles
qu'éventuellement les iraniens allait
nous tiraient dessus lesquels iraniens
n'avaient pas de missiles mais ça
n'avait l'air de déranger personne et
surtout qu'on aille à installer en
pologne des missiles pour répondre à des
missiles iraniens n'avait non plus l'air
bref on s'est foutu de tout le monde
mais maintenant la décision a été prise
et ses missiles vont être installés
çà parce que world a signé et il est
sorti avec son air m'as tu vu la disant
mes réserves ont été entendus en matière
militaire il n'y a pas de réserve tu es
d'accord ou t'es pas d'accord
ça n'existe pas des réserves à propos de
l'install sion d'une batterie
antimissile qu'est-ce que ça peut bien
être que ses réserves de dire on ne
tirera qu'après avoir demandé mon avis
mais hollande est un personnage
totalement inconsistant en matière de
défense parce que vraisemblablement il
n'y connais rien je sais pas ce qu'il y
améliorer son niveau mais je me rappelle
d'une fois où nous étions socialiste lui
et moi et on fait une un meeting dans le
pas de calais par un meeting inter dans
votez pour le congrès et voilà qu'au
milieu il était là dans un délire
européiste habituel chez ce genre de
personnage et il dit il faut que nous
fassions déjà l'europe de la défense qui
ensuite est venu pour lui la raison
principale de l'europe la raison d'être
c'est l'europe de la défense pour
françois hollande et est donc y compris
la question du nucléaire se trouve posée
vaqueront aussi un europe de la défense
et oui moi venir un maquereau après
parce que dans le domaine des idioties
chacun apporte son sac une tribu sion
singulière mais là je vous parle de
hollande je termine je vous promets de
pas être long et donc j'ai le temps je
tape sur la table comme ça il dit
attends stop alors mon petit moment je
dis tu veux dire que on met la
dissuasion nucléaire en commun et il
commence par faire alors pourquoi pas et
je lui dit mais tu es fou toi mais pas
28 doigt sur un but on ne fait pas une
réunion avant il te reste deux trois
quatre cinq minutes pour décider ce que
tu fais c'est une responsabilité
horrible 1 je ne dis pas que je peux pas
prendre cette responsabilité mais ça
fait partie du truc
ça fait partie du truc de l'évaluation
qu'on a à faire bon maintenant ce que je
sais comme tout le monde sait que la
dissuasion c'est une arme posthume en un
c'est à dire que le temps que vous la
mettiez en là vous êtes mort bon voilà
c'est comme ça il faut espérer que
personne ne fasse jamais ça c'est la
raison pour laquelle les français au
lieu de pousser à la roue et d'applaudir
tout ce que font les américains de
mettre le pied sur le frein en
particulier car les amériques a rompu le
traité avec les russes figurez-vous que
maintenant on est moins bien protégée
qu'on était du temps de l'union
soviétique
est-ce qu'on peut encore mettre le pied
sur le frein
ab c'est toute une stratégie il faut
faire beaucoup de choses en même temps
il faut pas rester là à regarder le bout
de ses chaussures et à attendre la suite
1 on peut aussi bougeait discutait à les
voir là à les voir l'autre essayer de se
comprendre avec beaucoup de monde en
europe parce que qui a intérêt à ce que
l'europe se transforme en un champ de
bataille qui a dit ça peut convenir un
truc pareil à personne sauf aux
américains parce que c'est loin de chez
eux s'il ya quelqu'un qui peut supporter
une frappe nucléaire c'est ceux pour qui
ce n'est pas un argument définitif il ya
que deux ou trois pays au monde qui sont
dans cette situation les nord américains
parce que leur territoire est immense et
que il compte bien que la bagarre
commence ailleurs c'est-à-dire en
l'occurence pendant longtemps chez nous
comme c'était d'un côté le camp
socialiste de l'autre côté l'ouest outre
que l'ouest avait tellement peur que ça
donne et les avantages sociaux mais
enfin l'est était à 48 heures
de paris
maintenant le deuxième pays qui peut
supporter ça c'est la chine
c'est une raison physique parce que
l'étendue du territoire et russie aussi
bien j'y viens il y en a plusieurs c'est
soit le nombre soit l'étendue du
territoire le nombreux vaut pour l'un
des pour la chine l'étendue du
territoire vaut pour la russie en plus
du nombre mais le nombre est moins
décisif en ce qui concerne les russes
par conséquent fondamentalement personne
n'ya intérêt on doit donc s'attendre en
tout cas les chinois n'en veulent pas
personne ne veut dit-on officiellement
de la guerre mais il n'est pas sûr que
les états unis est une culture de la
paix je sais que ça choque que je dis ça
mais les états unis en 229 ans
d'existence ont deux cent vingt années
de guerre
permanente
cité une guerre hors de ses frontières
de la chine au cours du siècle dernière
n a pas
les russes ont été envahi
et non envahi personne
à part nous après qu'on les ait envahi
donc ça c'est le 18e le 19e siècle un
peu au début donc par là je veux dire
qu' il n'est pas vrai qu'on soit dans
une situation où on ne peut peser sur
rien parce qu'il ya plein de gens qui
ont intérêt au désarmement et nous on
doit pouvoir dire oui nous sommes
d'accord pour le dire moments notamment
le désarmement nucléaire alors que toute
notre dissuasion repose là-dessus mais
évidemment que la discussion commence
pas par le fait de combien les français
vont enlever la discussion commence par
combien vous qui était plus puissant que
vous allez enlever et puis deuxièmement
quel accord on passe des détails qui
passe inaperçu du débat public en france
et du débat politique l'abolition du
traité sur les missiles dont je viens de
vous parler 405 de quatre cent cinquante
à cent mille kilomètres ça une
conséquence et ce en a eu ils ont fait
ça comme ça parce que il pense que la
stratégie à la reagan fonctionnaient à
nouveau c'est à dire mettre une pression
sur la russie telle qu'elle pourra pas
suivre et que donc elle cédera en route
mais il y a de sa part une
méconnaissance du mécanisme particulier
de l'économie de guerre dans une
économie capitaliste dans une économie
socialiste dans une économie socialiste
tout ce qui est mis dans l'armement et
puise là la matrice productive dans une
économie capitaliste c'est le contraire
tout ce que vous mettez en armement
basse et de la production c'est du pib
cc c'est de l'emploi et peu importe à
quoi ça sert et de temps à autre on vide
les caisses sont vides les soutes et on
va bombarder tel ou tel pays pour lui
balancer tout ce qui reste et qui marque
plus très bien c'est ce que c'est ce que
les américains ont fait avec la syrie
mais je reviens à la question des
missiles intermédiaire mais bien sûr je
vois que vous souriez mais de manger
sourit pas
ce qu'ils ont balancé en syrie à la à
l'algérie mais bien sûr demandez vous
vous souvenez à chaque fois qu'ils
intervenaient nous avons tiré 500
tomawak il faut se rendre compte de ce
que c'est qu'un missiles tomahwak c'est
un machin qui fait plusieurs mètres de
long qui voue une somme folle alors donc
qu'on tire 500 tomawak est la guerre
continue après comme si de rien n'était
ça veut donc dire qu'on a balancé ce
qu'on préférait balancé que de démonter
ou de désarmer je vous dis ça juste pour
le sourire mais pas que pour le sourire
parce que quand ils ont balancé tout ça
les hôtes ont répliqué avec des missiles
des missiles sam sauf par 400 jusqu'au
200 e 10 c les russes qui dit savoir si
c'est vrai ou pas c'est autre chose ça
les militaires français de le savoir en
attendant jeudi à une conséquence il
annule un traité de
sur les missiles on peut dire bon on
s'en fout on ne s'en fout pas parce que
le résultat ça pas été ce qu'a cru
monsieur trempe
ni de son prédécesseur à supposer que
les présidents américain décide quelque
chose en dehors de la bonne volonté des
différents services de ce pays mais
parler d état dans l'état oui fond oui
et à kiffer système on peut y revenir
dans un instant je termine juste pendant
la guerre en syrie les russes ont fait
un exploit militaire ils ont tiré un
missile depuis la mer noire qui a frappé
une cible en syrie c'est à dire qu'on
est là à nouveau sur plusieurs milliers
de kilomètres alors si l'oncle sam
pensait qu'en faisant peur il
empêcherait les russes de produire le
matériel qui leur permet d'être à la
hauteur des nouvelles conditions
politiques c'est un échec total donc la
raison veut que l'on fasse à nouveau des
propositions des armements il y en a
t'il sur la table oui il y en a une
c'est les chinois qui l'ont fait pour le
désarmement nucléaire multilatéral
ils l'ont fait à l'onu
ça nous amènera sur le sujet de la place
de l'onu si on parle de ça et pourquoi à
mon avis ça doit être l'un sens de
référence pour les français la seule
régulation internationale qu'on peut
admettre c'est celle de l'onu dont je
rappelle à chaque fois que l'occasion
s'en présente qu'elle comporte un
commandement militaire intégré
il n'y a donc aucun besoin particulier
d'avoir un commandement militaire
intégré de l'otan qui est tout autre
chose qui nous transforme en supplétifs
de l'armée américaine donc ce que je
veux dire c'est que j'attire l'attention
sur le fait qu'on ait à nouveau dans une
escalade
de l'armement et que dans cette escalade
ceux qui servent d'aliments sont les
plus irresponsables
je veux citer les pays baltes qui ont
une haine dont on peut comprendre les
motivations
absolument
russophobe délirante
acquis nous accordons beaucoup trop de
crédit parce que nous faisons semblant
de croire que la russie à l'intention
d'envoyer quelqu'un là russie n'a
naturellement l'intention d'envahir
personne parce qu'on ne voit pas en quoi
son intérêt serait impliqué dans telle
invasion en particulier des pays baltes
alors on suit ces gens là mêmes nous
français nous avons du matériel des
armes ce que les français ne savent pas
parce que personne ne leur a jamais
parlé ni consulté ça va de soi et pour
la première fois depuis 300 ans il y à
des soldats français à la frontière
russe avec une cinquantaine de chars
avec une centaine de pilotes qui se
répartissent entre pays baltes et
pologne tout ça est absurde tout ça est
absurde ne sert à rien sinon qu'à
provoquer il est évident qu'il moindre
conflit éclate et tous ces gens là
serait mort en moins de temps qu'il leur
faut pour se rendre compte du fait que
le conflit a commencé et ce sont des
provocations inutiles de la même manière
qu'à plusieurs reprises les bateaux
français sont entrés dans la mer noire
les bateaux militaires
où il n'avait rien de particulier à
faire dans les moments de tension entre
la russie l'ukraine bon c'était une
manière de positionner par rapport à la
crimée que les français y faire quoi la
guerre aux russes tout ça est absurde
alors tout que les élites vous est ce
que pour vous c'est une façon de chiens
allégeance aux états unis à son public
ah oui mais le j'ai évoqué olemps on
peut supposer que c'est parce qu'il n'a
aucune idée sur la question encore que
sa culture profonde c'est un clintonien
hollande c'est un clinton hien de la
première heure que dis je de la première
seconde c'est moi qui retrouvait les
textes de monsieur hollande de l'époque
83 où il embraye sur le groupe clinton
qui était à l'époque n'était pas encore
majoritaires au parti démocrate parce
qu'à l'époque hollande avait écrit un
article avec d'autres qu'en 1983 où il
disait pour être moderne soyons
démocrate est née des propos qui est
absolument insupportable à l'époque qui
le sont toujours pour moi aujourd'hui
mais qui parce qu'il n'a perçu
puisque on était en pleine période du
programme commun de l'alliance a été
communiste et raconter toute une série
de sornettes qui ensuite sont devenues
publiques puisque c'était le programme
de clinton le mouvement démocrate
socialiste est à mi chemin entre
l'entreprise et des travailleurs bla bla
bla bla enfin tout ce truc qui a servi
de véhicule au néolibéralisme donc ça a
été ça pour pour hollande quant au
président actuel
je vais en profiter pour vous dire une
autre chose parce que
son attitude est celle d'un atlantiste
ya rien dans ce qui fait qu'ils ne
soient pas atlantiste
aujourd'hui il est dit que la russie
devait devait rester au conseil de
lampes
mais encore heureux
la russie fait partie des fondateurs
quelqu'un à l'intention de demander
l'exclusion de la russie
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ce genre de
déclarations
c'est pas ça le problème de prendre ses
caisses kung fu commandement intégré de
l'otan
pourquoi on donne raison
systématiquement à n'importe quel
olibrius qui au nom de l'ukraine
montrent les dents aux russes quel est
le sens de cette politique pourquoi
est-il systématiquement aligné sur les
états unis d'amérique pourquoi est il
pris cette position grotesque sur le
venezuela sinon pour être d'accord avec
30 parce que venezuela et cuba c'est le
ticket d'entrée au club faut cracher
dessus et où remuer ses petits biscotos
et à ce moment là allez on est de la
famille et voilà comment la france se
trouve embarqué à les soutenir un
putschiste qui n'a rien dans le ventre
que monsieur gaido dans une situation
aberrante au venezuela
pour le reste je je passe le fait que
deux capitulation en capitulation et à
la fin vous êtes un pays vassal nous
sommes un pays vassal des états unis
d'amérique pourquoi parce que les états
unis d'amérique ont décidé que leur
législation
s'appliquer de manière extraterritoriale
du dollar et ainsi de suite aba'a temps
c'est pas rien la loi m blanc tonnes +
le fait qu'il a durci maintenant
notamment par rapport à cuba ben on est
tous les caniches ont dit oui comme ils
ont commencé par se coucher sur la
question de l'iran quand l'accord a été
signé avec les iraniens la diplomatie
française à jouer un bon rôle là dedans
à il faut lui reconnaître sa tef a vu ce
qu'était le ministre des affaires
étrangères ça a été très dur à obtenir
il ya eu un accord bon les l'iran
s'engager à ne pas avoir d'armement
nucléaire et un certain nombre de
garanties ont été discutés alors on
n'est jamais sûr de rien bien sûr mais
il vaut mieux un processus de
désarmement comme processus d'armement
arrive monsieur trempe qui en lien
étroit avec le gouvernement
d'extrême droite en israël décide que
non on va passer ça par dessus bord
alors je comprends que les gouvernements
d'israël soit extraordinairement
méfiants à l'égard de l'iran je vais pas
dire qu'ils ont tort parce que les
gouvernements iraniens tiennent des
propos à propos de d'israël qui sont une
menace de mort pour ce pays des gens qui
sont pendus des femmes qui sont pondus
et non mais ça n'a rien à voir avec le
sujet parce que ça on l'a déjà fait pour
l'afghanistan d'aller libérer
l'afghanistan résultat on s'est retrouvé
à prouver la charia une constitution
qu'on a mis au point avec eux tous les
curés du coin et il n'y a absolument
rien de changé donc de grâce ne
mélangeons pas tout les sujets là on
parle de choses qui concernent les
relations internationales et nous
n'avons ni amis ni ennemis nous des
intérêts et nos intérêts nous conduisent
à dire que nous devrons plutôt préféré
un accord de désarmement avec l'iran et
le fait qu'ils renoncent au nucléaire
que le contraire qu'elle bras de fer que
les états unis d'amérique ont organisé
contre l'iran je suis persuadé que le
peuple iranien
trouvera sans monsieur trump
les voix de sa liberté et de son
émancipation d'accord pour ma part je
n'ai jamais pas un seul jour à prouver
le régime des mollahs j'ai même eu
l'honneur de faire partie des gens qui
se considérait comme des ennemis
d'accord parce que quand
l'imam je crois qu'on a pris comme ça
khomeiny était à neauphle-le-château il
y avait des organisations de gauche qui
faisait le service d'ordre du libérateur
de l'iran moi j'ai toujours dit la même
chose aucun régime théocratique de me
convient et quelle que soit la soutane
les curés n'a rien à faire en politique
il faut qu'ils s'occupent de la fois de
la gestion de la fois de la religion
c'est leur affaire mais en politique non
personne où que ce soit quelle que soit
la soutane ça vaut aussi bien pour le
dalaï lama que pour l'imam khomeiny
imaginaire vous croyez en quelque chose
une religion c'est toujours gênant
d'abord des sujets je vais vous dire
pourquoi bien sûr j'ai un imaginaire
comme tout le monde je peux aussi dire
que j'ai une forme de mystique
qu'on va dire matérialiste 1 parce que
je fais partie de ces gens
c'est une petite phrase que j'aime bien
cité de ray bradbury vous voyez bradbury
c'est le l'auteur de science fiction
qu'ont-ils fait qu'ils aient dit je
crois à la magie
qimni à la plus petite poussière de
l'univers je croise à vous dire ce que
ça veut dire c'est comme toutes les
formules un peu magique
il ya une partie à bord flou alors oui
ça je peux le dire c'est pas c'est pas
gênant d'en parler mais après des
comptes dans le domaine des convictions
religieuses j'ai une ligne personnelle
sur le sujet je pense que quelqu'un qui
veut représenter le peuple et c'est ce
que nous sommes tous députés 1
doit pas mettre en avant de convictions
religieuses personnelles moi je
représente tout le monde les musulmans
les juifs les chrétiens j'ai été élevé
dans la foi chrétienne catholique
au douar présent doit pouvoir
représenter tout le monde et pardon de
rappeler leur existence les 60% de
français qui monte pas de conviction
religieuse particulière sauf lorsqu'ils
sont à l'agonie houle a souvent changé
d'avis sur la question mais la base des
français est globalement
tolérant et indifférent à la religion
mais refusent que la religion en dans le
politique les français aiment pas la
religion ostentatoire n'aime pas la
religion sectaire alors ça fait que des
fois ça les conduit à se trouver à la
frontière de l'intolérance mais la
bienveillance de départ est totale alors
moi j'aime pas dire j'aime pas aborder
ces sujets parce que je ne veux pas
créer de distance avec
ce que je veux représenter et j'ajoute
c'est aussi affectif je ne veux pas
créer de distance avec des religions
dans lesquels je n'ai pas été élevé moi
j'ai vécu toute ma vie avec des
musulmans j'ai pas envie de tracer
des frontières
revenons revenons camp d'été sur les
accords signés vernement venir avoir
parenthèses la chine ça remet beaucoup
en ce moment sur des technologies
d'intrusion des technologies aériennes
ça vous pose des problèmes et c'est quoi
et lorsque des offres is off re des
options désarmement aux autres mais
derrière ils s'arment sur les techniques
sont pas naïfs il fut c'est curieux
pourquoi alors de vendre et on a d'être
les seuls naïf non quand on est une
nation montrer l'exemple
quand on veut être une nation
indépendante
il faut se mettre dans la situation de
ne pas pouvoir se faire imposer une
décision par l'extérieur si l'espèce
c'est mme parent avait lancé sa
chasse est un vieil adage latin si vis
pacem para bellum si tu veux la paix
prépare la guerre
ça s'est toujours terminé par la guerre
il faut bien le dire mais moi je dis les
choses plus simplement on ne doit pas
laisser les autres être en situation de
vous dominez ses skis avec génial dans
la dissuasion
jeudi au passé parce qu'il n'est pas sûr
que ce soit encore un argument efficace
aujourd'hui puisque la dissuasion
française
repose entièrement sur le fait que nos
sous marins soit indétectable
du moment qu'ils le sont c'est fini
parce qu'on sait d'où sera tiré
pour cela je vous dis il ya un doute
d'où sera tiré nos armes bon mais la
dissuasion cdu du faible au fort c'est à
dire que le très fort c'est qui va en
prendre plein la figure donc il doit
réfléchir à l'inconvénient qui a agressé
des gens aussi aux têtu et féroce que le
sont les français alors les chinois
pardon puisque vous étiez sur les
chinois les chinois se mettent à niveau
au meilleur niveau technique possible
les européens avec une indifférence
europe et au centre est absolument
ridicule ont commencé par regarder de
haut les chinois dans notre pays en
particulier ou n'importe quel fadaises
colportées par
les milieux de la social-démocratie et
ce qui touche au tour deviennent des
lieux communs alors en france la seule
pensée qu'on avait sur la chine c'était
le dalaï lama voilà ce qui intéressait
les dirigeants politiques bon et lorsque
en 2010 je publie le livre qui s'appelle
qu'ils s'en aillent tous à la fin il ya
une petite partie internationale et
jeudi il faut avoir des accords de
coopération privilégiée avec les chinois
parce que c'est une puissance en
expansion technique matérielle et que ça
vaut mieux discuter avec eux avec qui on
a des points communs pour se comprendre
que avec les nord américains qui sont
une puissance déclinante agressive et
hostile à tout le monde et qui veut
dominer tout le monde voilà alors je ne
vous dis pas si demain c'était les
chinois qui vous laisse deviner il
faudrait s'entendre avec d'autres ma
logique elle est ni pro intel nippo un
autre est les indépendances nous devons
être maître de nous-mêmes et être maître
de nous mêmes c'est savoir naviguer dès
fois entre plus puissant que soit alors
cette technique là c'est pas moi qui les
ai inventées
elles ont été pratiquées du longtemps
c'est à dire quand on a fait le
contraire on a vu prix que ça coûte
d'accord quand par exemple nous sommes
encerclés par un empire ce qui nous est
arrivé au moment des habsbourgs bas on
est très mal les français ont c'est
comme ça quand on se fâche avec les
russes ça tourne toujours mal pour nous
donc ça vaut la peine d'y réfléchir 1
quand on veut faire comme ça les cliques
et aller braver tout le monde avec
quatre chars et trois avions un faut
réfléchir avant de se mettre dans des
situations inextricables
parce que celui qui veut faire des
démonstrations de force et qui en est
incapable ou qui s'avère être le faible
réel se met dans une situation qui est
pire après qu'avant
si vous dites vous allez voir ce que
vous allez voir et qu'on voit rien
clairement vous vous dévalorisez alors
ça veut dire que pour l'instant la
puissance agressive envahissante qui
intimide qui donne des ordres qui triche
dans la partie dans laquelle joue ce
sont les états unis d'amérique qui
impose des amendes à tour de rôle toutes
les grandes entreprises françaises et
aux autres entreprises ce sont les états
unis d'amérique fait quoi alors ou
l'ordi andy tu restes chez toi tu nous
embête puis nous sort du dollar il nous
faut une guerre économique saignante ils
ont une technique sera évidemment c'est
des passants vous savez le depuis
depuis le 16e siècle et le texte de la
boétie on sait que la servitude et
souvent volontaire et comme il dit ils
sont d'autant plus puissants que nous
mettons à genoux mais on peut tenir tête
on n'est pas obligé de le faire d'une
manière agressive mais déjà on commence
par sortir du commandement intégré
qu'est ce qu'on fait là dedans qu'est ce
qu'on fait là dedans ça rapporte quoi
par l'amélioration de la paye des
officiers supérieurs français qui y
participent qu'est ce que ça nous donne
ça me donne le bonheur de quoi même pas
d'avoir le contrôle sur la 6ème flotte
qui patrouille en méditerranée et la
méditerranée c'est chez nous c'est pas
chez les américains ils n'ont pas de
frontières avec la méditerranée les
américains alors qu'est ce qu'ils
foutent là qu'est ce qu'ils foutent là
avec la sixième flotte leurs vingt mille
hommes de troupe leur matériel qu'est ce
qu'ils font là ils sont là pour qui pour
quoi pour défendre qui contre quoi non
il sera pour rien d'autre que pour
manifester leur arrogance puissance et
leur capacité à menacer tout le monde où
est le quartier général des nord
américains il est en italie où est la
plus grosse base en europe des
nord-américains coucou surprise le
kosovo ah bon oui on a créé le kosovo
que pour ça ça c'est la politique réelle
le reste c'est du blabla céder donc
c'est d'eux dont il faut se mettre à
distance mais on peut le faire en leur
expliquant pour qu'on fait et puis des
américains sont pas tous trump il ya
aussi sanders aux états unis d'amérique
6 enders avait été candidat à l'élection
présidentielle les sondages le donnaient
gagnant contre 30 pour deuxième tour
pourquoi parce que trump a gagné en
ayant les voix des petits blancs c'est à
dire des ouvriers abandonné par le parti
démocrate américain comme ils ont été
abandonnés en europe par les partis
sociaux démocrates
et par le plus puissant d'entre eux le
parti social démocrate allemand qui
participent à une coalition avec la
droite si bien qu en allemagne c'est
ferme ta bouche et comme cela domine le
parlement européen au parlement européen
c'est ferme ta bouche et dans le groupe
social démocrate européen ferme ta
bouche et les français comme par hasard
ils ont quelque chose à dire je parle
des sociaux démocrates français eh bien
on leur dit vous êtes minoritaires
qu'est ce que vous voulez et voilà ça se
passe comme ça on ferme sa bouche en
allemagne et du coup on ferme sa bouche
partout et tout ça aboutit à les états
unis d'amérique pourquoi parce que
l'allemagne a une culture politique
d'être défendue par les états unis
d'amérique pendant toute la guerre
froide
tandis que nous les français nous avons
une autre culture si bien que le langage
que je vous dis à la choque ceux qui
vont me regarder en partie et puis
surtout les étrangers comme tu es
certain allemand certains suédois
certains d'anouar et pas les autres
parce que le rejet de l'otan il existe
dans tous les pays de repas pourrait pas
croire que c'est une lubie de jean luc
mélenchon 1 il ya un courant anti otan
en espagne en italie en allemagne et
ainsi de suite
donc le problème qui nous est posée
c'est comment nous unissons nos forces
et comment elle elle arrive à faire en
sorte qu'on renverse la situation donc
moi j'ai dit depuis le premier jour si
je gouvernait le pays oui la première
chose que je ferai c'est sortir de du
commandement intégré de l'otan sans
doute de l'otan construire une autre
alliance
et faire baisser la pression avec les
russes
avec the deck les russes avec tous ceux
qui seraient d'accord pour avoir comme
priorité cette indépendance et
souveraineté populaire on doit pouvoir
trouver des alliés un peu partout ce qui
est sûr c'est qu'on ne peut pas trouver
des alliés si on arrive comme ça
monsieur pour une vous savez il ya eu un
moment il y avait la coalition des
non-alignés bon alors comme tout le
monde avait les doigts dedans à la fin
n'était pas si non alignés que ça mais
enfin qui a existé et puis si ce sont
les français qui lance le mouvement
vous verrez on aura des surprises encore
faut-il pouvoir discuter parce que la
dernière campagne présidentielle
comme vous le savez
les dans les 10 derniers jours il y a eu
je suppose une note de service des
services et j'ai été tout d'un coup
pendant dix jours agressé sur le thème
que je voulais quitter l'union
européenne pour adhéré à l'alba
c'est-à-dire à l'alliance
à l'alliance latino-américaine des
bolivarienne voilà cette invention
je crois que le personnage le plus
grotesque qui est lancée ça c'est
monsieur aphatie qui a dit avec eux avec
les iraniens et russes c'est moche ouais
c'est moche c'est moche de raconter des
conneries de ce niveau là
quand on prétend être journaliste donc
on voit qu'il ya un lobby qui est
continuellement à l'oeuvre pour couvrir
les positions nord-américaine et
garantir que ne se produise pas la
catastrophe qu'ils craignent tous c'est
que quelque part en europe crack un
maillon de la chaîne on a cru que ce
serait en grèce ça ne s'est pas produit
puisque chip race a retourné sa veste et
ils ont eu très peur que ça soit ici en
france parce que c'est un des cinq pays
du centre capitaliste mondiale et que
tout d'un coup ils découvrent ce type
qui s'appelle mélenchon comment vous
dites porté par des millions de gens et
en même temps ils ont eu très peur chez
eux parce que sanders
leur a quand même à raser la moustache
la sender c'est un nouveau parti en
campagne
moi j'espère que évidemment si le centre
numéro un mondial changer d'orientation
ça y est le monde est sauvé
c'est clair que le plus intéressant pour
nous c'est que senders gagne parce que
ça nous fait un interlocuteur je ne vous
dis pas qu'on dirait la même chose
je crois que je connais un peu assez le
monde anglo saxon pour savoir qu' il
faut pas trop compter sur autre chose
qu'une bonne compréhension mutuelle des
intérêts mutuels dans les regrets
un petit peu mais par sectarisme et
sottise j'en conviens j'ai cessé de le
parler et du coup maintenant que j'ai le
plus grand mal à m'exprimer en anglais
et comme disons par principe je veux pas
parce que le français est une des
langues de l'onu c'est une des deux
langues de l'onu
que en europe nous avons été humiliés
puisque maintenant on n'a plus les
traductions des documents en français il
faut les demander et ça demande un délai
qui est incompatible avec le système
ridicule du fonctionnement du parlement
européen où une dernier texte arrive la
veille pour le lendemain matin
et je défends le je défends ma pratique
mon droit à la pratique de la langue
française
j'ajoute que pour faux pas de complexe
le continent qui est en pleine explosion
c'est l'afrique n'osions démographique
si bien que
si nous sommes encore tous là dans
trente ou quarante ans il n'y a pas eu
une catastrophe
majeure nous serons la troisième langue
parlée dans le monde mais elle sera
surtout parlé par des africains ce qui
personnellement me réjouis parce que je
trouve que ça sera une manière de
revitaliser cette langue est peut-être
d'habituer les
les français à se réjouir de ça se
réjouir de dette de pouvoir entrer en
contact avec des gens qui parlent notre
langue parce que pour l'instant je
trouve que ça le fait pas il ya 100
millions de personnes qui parlent le
français dans le maghreb
et c'est comme s'ils n'existaient pas et
la seule chose qu'on aurait alors dire
c'est
qu'ils se vouent on a peur de vous
qu'est-ce que vous avez identifié comme
menace ne peut pas comme menace on a un
copain qui a écrit un bouquin qui
s'appelle introduction ou siècle des
menaces jauge rire ou siècle des menaces
ouais c'est notre ami jacques blamont
fondateur du prince spatial français je
n'ai pas lu qu'est ce que vous vous
identifiez comme menace ou la court
moyen long terme est alors à court terme
c'est le dérèglement climatique et la
chute de l'equilibre de l'écosystème
parce que deux là vont partir tout le
reste est à peu près on a des outils
pour le contrôler elle sert à rien le
système financier qui se vouent temps
c'est non mais je commence d'abord après
et hiérarchie vous débrouillerez mais
commençons par dire ça pour quoi parce
que la vraie menace c'est quand il ya
plus d'instruments pour faire face à la
menace
si l'écosystème s'effondre la forme ce
que ça va prendre d'abord ça sera pas
graduelle
ça sera par paliers et ça provoque
immédiatement des conséquences
géopolitiques personne ne contrôle
exemple
une forme de réchauffement climatique
qui provoque une famine à un endroit des
millions de gens se déplacent ils
passent la frontière là il n'y a plus de
frontières il n'y a plus rien qui tient
le pays voisin s'écroule puis pays
voisins s'écroule et c'est pour ça que
les américains ont fait injure
c'est pas pour ça parce que comme idée
stupide ya peu au dessus un mur on pour
empêcher les mexicains de passer mais
n'importe quel mur est une connerie je
vais vous raconte souvent ça parce que
de faire il disait ça gaston defferre un
ancien maire de marseille il disait nous
pendant la guerre on avait de ce côté là
la wehrmacht la gestapo et la ministre
de l'autre côté on avait la guardia
civil et les phalangistes 1 et on peut
c'est quand même alors qu'est ce qu'ils
croient qui va empêcher les gens de
passer mais pas de technologie à vous
croyez que la technologie va empêcher
quelqu'un de passer
c'est la technologie était capable
d'empêcher des choses de cette nature il
ya plus de cafards dans votre maison et
ainsi de suite non pour pour eux je veux
d'abord l'air des ménages jeudi d'abord
ça tient ou ça c'est la forme la plus
durable c'est-à-dire ce qui peut
provoquer un effondrement irréversible
nous avons eu des prémices de situation
d'effondrement de l'état pour des
raisons différentes mais on a déjà vu ça
liberia sierra leone on a vu pendant une
décennie deux décennies ce qu'on
appelait les zones grises à dire on ne
s'est jusqu'ici pas dedans ni qui
commande
donc ça c'est la menace parce que ni
vous ni moi on est capable de dire de
quelle façon ça se déclenche mais on est
sûr que ça va avoir lieu alors si les
légendes du giec raconte pas de bêtises
ils disent qu'on a 12 ans avant que se
manifeste le dérèglement climatique
il y at il une chance qu'on empêche vous
répond franchement non
non parce que les engagements des pays
consignait la coop 21 conduisent à 3°
25,2 de réchauffement climatique donc de
toutes façons la paire est perdu
sauf si un le sauf si c'est se mettre
quasiment dans une situation d' économie
de guerre pour faire muter le système et
c'est même pas sûr qu'on y arrive comme
ça que c'est pire en pire la route ou
oui oui son économie de guerre enlever
1000 milliards pour sauver le vrai mais
je le texte qui m'a le plus intéressé
c'est
celui de
pablo serving
et notamment son bouquin sur l'entr'aide
parce que j'ai trouvé que je crois pas
que les livres en tout cas ce qui arrive
jusqu'à moi il arrive jamais jusqu'à moi
innocemment il fallait qu'il m'arrive
donc il est arrivé à plein de gens même
temps et on en parle après si vous
voulez mais l'intérêt c'est de dire
comment on fait quand on entre dans une
période de crise avec la mentalité
d'avant la crise si on en d'actifs
globale totale liée à l'effondrement de
l'écosystème avec des comportements
égoïstes et de compétition libre et non
faussée qui prévalent dans la période
actuelle ces ruines lui-même dit si vous
faites ça la crise sera plus dur pour
vous encore quelle qu'elles ne le
devraient l'être alors j'ai cité
l'effondrement de l'écosystème
j'ai évoqué
le monde donc j'ai pris l'exemple d'une
sécheresse donc pour en prendre d'autres
par exemple
les vagues exceptionnelles c'était 20
mètres il ya trente ans de ça
aujourd'hui la vague exceptionnelle ses
40 mètres vagues scélérates dont vous
pouvez imaginer
que 90 pour cent du commerce mondial se
faisant par la mer et via bull petit
temps 6 représentant une part infime des
échanges en dollars du monde je veux
dire les échanges réels des échanges qui
ont lieu les échanges réels sont la
partie la plus faible bref si vous
imaginez que pour une raison pour une
autre les océans deviennent moins
praticables qu'ils le sont aujourd'hui
par des navires qui sont de plus en plus
longs et qui si les choses continuent
comme elles sont seront de plus en plus
large ça peut faire sourire
mais si on peut passer par le nord il ya
toutes sortes de chemins qui ne sert
plus à rien notamment ceux qui passent
par les grands canaux suez etc on peut
passer ailleurs et autrement
bon alors le dérèglement peuvent avoir
des conséquences de formes diverses et
multiples après il ya la question de la
deuxième grande menace c'est évidemment
la menace de la crise financière celle
là elle est comme la menaces sur les
colos l'écosystème c'est une certitude
que la crise aura lieu la prochaine
le système capitaliste a jamais été un
système stable contrairement à ce que
laisse croire ses thuriféraires c'est un
système qui a toujours fonctionné crise
en crise parce que il est construit sur
des contradictions qui produit ces
crises la contradiction fondamentale
c'est le caractère social de la
production et caractère privé de
l'appropriation
qui fait que toutes les crises sont des
crises de surproduction alors après on
s'interroge en quoi consiste la
surproduction elle peut consister
simplement dans le fait qu'il ya pas de
demande solvable c'est à dire une
charentaise vous êtes pour la croissance
la décroissance
il va falloir qu'on s'entende sur les
mots
si la croissance
c'est la croissance du pib comment
connaît aujourd'hui honnêtement
c'est absurde creusé un trou puis
boucher cinq minutes après ça augmente
le pipe dans les deux cas ça ne sert
strictement à rien on peut s'interroger
sur ce qu'on appelle des richesses quand
on dit on sache et les richesses oui à
partager les richesses
c'était une expression qu'on a pris dans
les années
90 2000 parce que ça faisait plus soft
que d'autres formules qui était un peu
plus radicale que bon mais pardon comme
comme les autres formules pyongyang a
exproprié
prendre
parce que je préfère dire le partage des
richesses parce que on entend le mot
richesses tout le monde qui c'est qui
les a produits à tiens c'est les mêmes
bons
pour les salles et saint leu leu
déséquilibré de plus en plus grand en
1986 vous travaillez 11 jours pour payer
les dividendes les salariés à travailler
pendant on joue aujourd'hui 45 jours
clairement les ont tout pris et les
autres russes qui restaient ça c'est
pour parler des richesses mais quand
nous parlons de la crise financière qui
menace c'est évidemment un petit peu
difficile à comprendre parce que on va
avoir une crise à cause de quelque chose
qui n'existe pas qui est une masse
monétaire gigantesque les américains ont
balancé dans le monde
en dollars parce qu'ils sont le seul
pays du monde qui appuie sur un bouton
pour faire cracher du dollar à leur
machine et personne ne leur demande
jamais la contrepartie matérielle par
exemple si vous moi et tous ceux qui
sont à cette pièce ou qui ne regarde on
avait notre jeu c'est pas nous à notre
piste de dollars 1 et puis on court
aussi tôt pour dire à moi j'y crois pas
ce truc à je vais acheter il y aura une
inflation qui serait absolument
gigantesque ce serait une inflation
je sais pas moi peut-être vous eu un
cent mille pour cent tout s'effondrerait
on parlera après du venezuela se peut
pas être au détour d'une phrase parce
que c'est un sujet qui passionne
beaucoup de monde puisque le venezuela
est un pays intéressant mais il y aurait
une hyperinflation qui détruirait
l'économie mondiale j'ai lu de
nombreuses de nombreux textes sur ce
sujet et surtout le plus intéressant
j'ai oublié le nom de l'auteur c'est un
très vieux livres de la gazza ou fait du
souci pour rien parce que si tout le
monde allait demander ces dollars dans
les banques
le temps qu'on les imprimait il faudrait
attendre et dans cette attente on
pourrait faire autre chose ensuite il
veut une fois que ont comme aussi on
peut pas les imprimés tout de suite on
vous donnera des papiers sur lequel il
est écrit que vous avez droit et donc ça
sera à nouveau de la monnaie disons la
chose suivante une bulle gigantesque de
monnaie sans contrepartie matériels
existent elles flottent les donner un
exemple pour nous téléspectateurs
comprennent la taille de cette bulle
quatre mille fois la production réelle
normalement je vais pas leur dire
n'importe quoi vous dites une pomme un
euro un bon imaginez que vous produisiez
en même temps derrière il ya 4000 euros
donc vous rappliquer 1go 4000 euros d'un
coup vous allez voir que le prix de
votre pomme il bondit parce qu'il faut
que la monnaie la monnaie est jamais
qu'une une intermédiation entre une
valeur réelle est une autre je sais
c'est un peu abstrait puis c'est pas le
moment de faire un cours de la théorie
marxiste de la neige sur le marché du
jeu sur notre chaîne youtube vous allez
vous avez affaire à une communauté qui
est très affûté sur ce type de sujet le
crois oui est il la bonne et vous pouvez
rentrer dans détails n'hésitez pas oui
je crois que j'ai dit l'essentiel dans
ma conception de la monnaie je crois que
la conception matérialiste de la monnaie
la monnaie est un intermédiaire entre
deux valeurs et elle même elle est une
valeur c'est pourquoi au départ par
exemple on trouve l'or comme mené parce
que l'or est lui même une production
matérielle qu'on arrive à transporter
plus facilement qu'ils concentrent
davantage de travail qu'une chaise une
table qu'on aurait du mal à porter sous
son bras une récolte etc donc si on part
de cette idée que le calories face sinon
sinon on doit partir de l'idée qu'il
signe monétaire doivent correspondre les
productions matérielles
si vous avez quatre mille fois plus de
signes monétaires qu'il n'ya de
production matérielle encore une fois si
nous courions tous avec tout cet argent
allait acheter ce qui est disponible on
aurait une hyper inflation parce que la
monnaie s'effondrait
c'est la hantise des états unis
d'amérique comment cette crise alors il
ya la crise comment dire par surprise
la crise par surprise
c'est un mauvais coucheur quelque part
qui déclenche bon par exemple un gars
qui a qui a acheté une maison et ils
paient une seule prime c'est une prime
supplémentaire parce qu'il a pas rond en
réalité il est pauvre alors le système
s'en fout parce qu'il prend son fric et
puis à un moment donné il a dit je peux
plus payer alors on lui dit va très bien
on vante la maison alors encore quelque
chose à prendre le système arrive à
tourner mais des fois non ça ce bloc ça
peut se bloquer n'importe où n'importe
quand à n'importe quelle heure du jour
ou de la nuit dans le monde
d'autant que les six les les les
circonstances aggravantes sont
innombrables là je viens d'évoquer les
ce prix parce que tout le monde a
entendu parler de cette histoire là en
mais on pourrait dire la dette étudiante
aux états unis qui est colossal et
aujourd'hui la dette privée dans le
monde est infiniment supérieur à la
dette publique et elle n'est pas de même
nature parce que si vous vous dites bas
je peux plus payer salut je sais pas
m'en vous suicidez vous vous dites je
peux plus payer c'est tout je peux plus
payer je peux plus payer je paye pas on
vient dit monsieur sisi vous allez payer
bac souligne le fasse
j'ai rien je paye pas rouler dans l'os
mais si vous êtes en état la dette
d'état les beaucoup plus sûr que la
dette privée parce que l'état on sait où
il est on sait où et son président sait
où et son gouvernement ou et son
parlement il paiera toujours l'état
c'est pourquoi quand la banque centrale
européenne a proposé de racheter des
titres de la dette des états que
posséder les banques puisque la banque
centrale européenne n'a pas le droit
d'acheter directement des titres de
dette des états ce qui dans la logique
libérale reviendra subventionner les
états donc ils achètent aux banques eh
bien les banques voulaient pas lâcher
leurs titres de dette des états les
mêmes banques qui gueulent contre la
dette publique et accessible à bla bla
bla bla sauf que quand ils ont des
titres ils les gardent ça n'empêche que
la banque centrale européenne a racheté
des titres des dettes des états et les a
dans ses coffres ce qui pour moi est une
circonstance admirable parce que ça va
nous permettre de l'effacer plus
facilement pour ça que j'ai proposé de
faire une conférence de la dette en
europe et je m'adresse aux capitalistes
si vous comprenez pas que vous avez
intérêt à effacer la dette publique
c'est que vous avez un pois chiche dans
le cerveau parce que quand tu va éclater
la dette privée si vous voulez qu on
réinjecte de l'activité en supposant que
le capitalisme continue il faut que les
états puissent le faire il faut qu'ils
puissent passer des commandes tout ce
que vous voulez pas faire aujourd'hui
les routes les ponts les voies ferrées
la transition de l'appareil de
production
c'est ça qui permettra de faire face à
la catastrophe
qui va arriver peut-être du côté de la
dette privée si elle arrive de quelque
part elle arrivera du côté de la dette
privée c'est pas un état qui va tomber
en faillite c'est un secteur de
l'économie qui va tomber en faillite
pour les raisons du bien nommé depuis
2008 la situation s'est aggravée
ce que en 2008 ils ont découvert les
corps heures comment tout ça était
intrigué les uns dans les autres mais
entre temps tout en prenant des airs
très important dit on à bâle deux bâle
iii on a augmenté les garanties c'est à
dire la proportion d'argent réel que
possèdent les banques par rapport aux
sont engagés c'est rien du tout mais si
c'était que ça une comédie qui est
destiné à rassurer et qui en fait ne
règle rien la fuite en avant dans
laquelle on se trouve mais ces contre
temps ils ont décidé de nouvelles
conneries par exemple en europe sous
l'impulsion de monsieur barnier on a
accepté que les entreprises titrisent
leur dette alors puisque vous me dites
que nos auditeurs sont moore affûté sur
la question mais je pense que tout le
monde comprend ce que ça veut dire donc
une une entreprise prête à une autre
offre à une autre ou empruntent à une
banque mais vous savez que le crédit
interentreprises progressivement arrive
au niveau du crédit qu'ils ont avec les
banques ce qui est absolument incroyable
ces gens se prêtent de l'argent entre
eux personne de contrôle à chacun croit
la bonne parole de l'autre un tuba pour
lui que tu me rendrai et ouais bon ben
alors nippo tiens je te prête à temps
la titrisation a permis découper ses
dettes et du foot dans des titres qui se
vendent de l'un à l'autre mais ça c'est
ça veut dire qu'à tout moment vous êtes
à la merci de l'effondrement de l'un ou
de l'autre je sais pas si bayern par
exemple pour prendre un exemple au
hasard
avait dit dette titrisée mais je pense
que ce qu'ils ont dans leur coffre comme
contrepartie à leurs empreintes des
titres de bayer peuvent commencer à se
faire du souci parce que bayer a voulu
racheter monsanto ils l'ont fait et
c'est une catastrophe parce que
aujourd'hui comme prévu pardon ça ne se
passe pas comme prévu ah ça c'est clair
que ça se passe pas comme prévu pour
l'instant c'est une faillite parce que
le titre bayern c'est quasiment écroulé
et que bon on va pas faire peur à tout
le monde mais ça c'est voilà le genre de
problème ça c'est c'est prévu nulle part
tout ça c'est écrit nulle part dans les
grands cahiers les grands livres la
puissante pensée de tous les économistes
qui vient de blablater à la télé un
passant a dit vous savez là il va y
avoir un problème avec le chimiste leur
jeu un peu oui
c'est moi parler de la catastrophe
financière il va y revenir tout de suite
j'ai évoqué à peu près tous les facteurs
je crois la la titrisation les secteurs
qui sont endettés sont pas capables de
rembourser le rôle des états unis
d'amérique qui n'ont dont le monde avec
leurs dollars est l'atout utilisons
c'est là dessus qu'on va venir je pense
dans un instant donc je veux comprendre
pourquoi leurs politiques et agressive
dans le monde oui c'est une fuite en
avant et on a l'impression à vous
entendre et réentendre certains autres
que on est dirigée par une bande de
cloportes qui fuit en avant quelque
chose qui est inextricable et qu' ils
sont dans le déni jusqu'au bout jusqu'à
la dernière seconde oui pourquoi la
société civile ne réagit pas pourquoi
nous intellectuels ne réagissent pas
pourquoi on les a pas au pied du mur en
leur disant écoute mon coco on a bien
compris que tu racontais que de la merde
depuis un certain de l'année pourquoi on
laisse faire parce qu'on est tombé dans
une population qui anesthésie qui ne
veut plus se battre comment d'abord
parce que les sociétés humaines ont
toujours été dominé par le pouvoir
imaginaire qu'elle produisait le même
bon donc beaucoup de gens pensent que le
marché pour autant qu'ils arrivent à y
comprendre quelque chose est un mode
efficace de régulation des activités
économiques et humaines il le croit je
suis persuadé que le président macron le
crois je pense que de sa vie n'a dû lire
un bouquin marxiste il n'a aucune espèce
d'idée sur ce qu'est une économie il
appelle ses administrés pour presser la
catastrophe totale bon même le
keynésianisme pour eux c'est c'est
l'horreur alors qu'ils ont sous les yeux
deux pays qui ont mis une petite
politique keynésienne
sympa mais patron pas trop anti libérale
en espagne au portugal des deux seuls
endroits où on à distribuer du pouvoir
d'achat aux gens ouf l'activité a repris
et en france la dette en fait on a
distribué de la capacité à s'endetter
c'est vrai mais le spica quand même
augmenté de 22% en espagne pour vous
teniez compte de ça c'est pas rien parce
que quand vous donner des sous à ceux
qui n'ont pas ou pas beaucoup et les
dépenses c'est normal et c'est pourquoi
sable et de l'activité en france ça fait
pas d'inflation on s'en fout quel est le
problème d'abord ils sont dans la zone
euro l'espagne
qu'à l'inflation et même pas 2 %
inflation on change un peu de sujet mais
je je veux répondre à ça parce que ça me
ça m'amusait m'intéresse l'inflation
mais tant mieux vivre l'inflation ils
ont balancé 85 milliards tous les mois
la banque centrale européenne dans les
banques privées en leur disant après un
processus qui a pris du temps au début
ils ont dit on vous donne des sous en
échange deux alors en échange de ya rien
eu on vous donne des soucis à la fin du
livre on vous donne des sous faites ce
que vous voulez avec 85 milliards tous
les mois poum poum au total
on doit être maintenant à un peu plus
d'une année de pib de la france
distribué comme ça qu'est l'inflation il
ya en europe
la façon quand même sur les actifs
tangibles genre l'immobilier des choses
comme ça c'est autre chose ça c'est
ponctuel mais ça c'est financièrement ça
ça a à voir avec le mécanisme
d'accumulation de l'économie capitaliste
sur des valeurs qui n'existe pas quand
le prix de l'autre immobilier monde
comme ça sans que vous ayez changé ni un
feu rouge nini en trottoir ni quoi que
ce soit vous voyez bien que c'est
spéculatifs et ça n'a rien à voir avec
l'inflation dont je parle moi qu'est
l'inflation globale en europe il
n'arrive même pas à 2% donc vous
balancer le pouvoir d'achat équivalent à
la production d'une année de la france
et vous avez même pas 2 % d'inflation
dans la zone euro et quand on y regarde
de près on dit ah bah du peu d'inflation
tient les deux tiers c'est à cause des
fluctuations des plus du prix de
l'énergie
autrement dit toute cette masse de
monnaie qu'ils ont mis en circulation
est allé directement dans la sphère
financière elle n'a pas touché en jour
le solde de la production réelle ça
c'est la démonstration ça veut dire que
la sphère financière ne rapporte pas
d'augmentation de pib el cid ans dans le
calcul du pib si encore qu'on calcule la
différence on sépare les deux activités
financières et non financières
mais bien sûr pour besoins n'importe
quoi a produit du pib
n'importe quoi produit du pib mais c'est
pas c'est pas un repère pour nous c'est
pour vous dire en fait on a injecté
énormément d'art on tourne en rond
mettez vous à la place d'un capitaliste
l'alerté bouder c'est vrai vous allez
vous allez placer vos sous dans
l'économie ce qu'on appelle l'économie
réelle vous savez que c'est un concept
est tout à fait discuté par les libéraux
et 10 mai par dont l'assurance et
l'économie réelle
bon cela dit par parenthèse il ne compte
pas dans les prélèvements obligatoires
même quand c'est obligatoire passant pas
son restons sur notre sujet ils ont
injecté des milliards dont on ne
retrouve pas trace dans ce que moi
j'appelle l'économie réelle c'est à dire
la production d'un bien ce que je
voulais vous dire un matériel
on peut dire aussi d'un service mais
après on va entrer dans une discussion
sur qu'est-ce qui est en service réel
qu'est ce qui n'en est pas un bon bref
en attendant supposons un puisque vous
avez l'air d'avoir peur de l'inflation
c'est sans doute que vous êtres entiers
vous supputer vous supputer un look
d'accord mais bon il faut bien on peut
sourire les gens qui me parlent de
l'inflation comme comme une catastrophe
je sais pas qui l'aurait alors
évidemment comme c'est une inflation à
1000% ou à 200% moi j'ai connu ça j'ai
vu une fois ce que c'était que
l'hyperinflation et j'ai vu en argentine
on a les billets coller au doigt parce
qu'il réimprimer dans la journée des
valeurs différentes de sueur ans je
comprends que ça fasse peur et c'est
vrai que ça fait peur mais une inflation
doute comme du niveau de celle dont je
parle c'est pas la même chose
supposons que la banque centrale
européenne rachète toutes les dettes des
états nations et décide que c'est des
dettes perpétuelles
voilà vous menez des sous alors si par
hasard vous avez des titres à vous les
maintenaient dans vos bilans bon leurs
liquidités est égal à zéro sauf si vous
avez besoin de mettre des petits tas de
temps à autre
stables ce que n'importe qui fait quand
vous faites des dd fond quel qu'il soit
de pension autre qui était que moi j'ai
jamais douté du fait que si vous est
rachetée par la banque centrale toutes
les dettes des états on redonne dans
seul coup à tous les états une capacité
d'intervention publique considérable
d'accords alors que cela produirait quoi
comme inflation dit oui mais c'est du ca
produira de l'inflation combien mais
combien bon sens j'ai dit 10 fois cette
proposition à chaque fois on dit
l'inflation qu'elle en place y ont
combien
qu'est ce qui vous fait peur j'ai vécu
dans un monde où on avait jusqu'à 12% en
inflation tout ce qu acheter leur maison
il frottait les mains en disant il est
plus de dette quel est votre problème
avec l'inflation la lutte des classes
est aggravée parce que comme il fallait
que les salaires rattrape la perte de
pouvoir d'achat et ben c'était comment
dire une société très animé sur la
question du partage des richesses bon
qu'elle est l'inflation qui vous fait
peur racheté toutes les dettes publiques
combien sacré d'inflation je vais vous
répondre mais je commence d'abord par
poser la question comment tous ceux qui
m'ont cassé les pieds sur le sujet ont
jamais été foutu de dire combien oui
combien j'ai demandé à jacques généreux
à sa pire et à d'autres combien à votre
avis ils m'ont dit 5 à 6% 5 à 6% on se
coupe la gorge pour ne pas avoir à payer
5 à 6 % d'inflation on supprime des
ponts des autoroutes des hôpitaux pour
ne pas avoir 5 à 6 % d'inflation mais
tout ça c'est une mascarade ça veut dire
que une petite poignée de gens
convaincus tous les autres d'une
connerie qui sert leurs intérêts et
l'intérêt de qui de la rente des
rentiers de l'allemagne
c'est eux qui par dessus tout ont bâti
ce modèle économique ça s'appelle l'ordo
libéralisme
alors évidemment tous les capitalistes
de tous les autres pays trouvait trop
vient de se décharger sur les allemands
de faire la sale besogne de faire lé
père la rigueur les pères et les mères
la rigueur bon avec thébaux absolument
invraisemblable à notre égard
jamais on a parlé nous une seule fois du
gouvernement allemand et de son
hinterland comme eux on parler de ce
qu'ils appellent le club med pour parler
des pays du sud mais qui sont ces gens
pour nous parler comme ça ils sont la
première économie oui écrit la deuxième
s'il vous plaît nous les français et la
troisième les italiens et la 4e les
espagnols le club med le voilà ce sont
les principales puissances économiques
de l'europe à qui ces gens se donne le
rôle de faire la leçon pour leur imposer
quelque chose qui ne correspond à rien
de nos besoins d'eau tradition voilà
alors pour revenir à cette histoire
d'inflation et de rachat de la dette moi
j'ai dit il faut une conférence
européenne de la dette voilà alors tout
le monde peut trier s'énerver ça ne sert
à rien il faut discuter de la dette
parce que je le répète ici personne ne
la paiera jamais je sais que ça choque
quand on dit ça personne ne paiera
jamais une dette pareil on pourra tous
les ans payé un petit peu mais vous êtes
en train d'annoncer aux générations qui
a l'a non seulement qu'elle aura même
plus la terre pour pouvoir y vivre mais
que si par hasard ils survivent ça sera
pour payer la dette tout ça est absurde
absurde ça n'a aucune raison ce sont des
jeux d'écriture alors évidemment le
commun des mortels quand il entend
parler de la dette il voit sa propre
dette il pense que le budget d'un état
c'est comme un budget familial mais non
ça n'a rien à voir parce qu'aucune
famille n'a le pouvoir de créer de la
monnaie il est assis aucune famille n'a
le pouvoir de effacer une dette les
états si des dettes on en efface tous
les ans et l'a mis en forme on a
beaucoup effacé un moment donné le
principal du crédit de la coopération en
france consiste à effacer des dettes
donc on disait cela ils doivent s'en
aller hop on oublie et on mettait en
positif on a donné tant oui on a donné
un truc existait déjà plus depuis un
moment vous voyez il faut déconstruire
tout ça faut l'expliquer mais vous
m'avez posé une question pourquoi les
gens pourquoi n'y a pas de réaction à ça
mais parce que le pouvoir imaginaire de
l'idéologie néolibérale a submergé tous
les esprits quand je parle comme je suis
en train de le faire si vous passez ce
film-là à toute une série de gens qui
sont des néolibéraux mille sont déjà
évanoui à la moitié de mon discours ce
type est irréaliste et c'est moi qui le
dis mais qu'est ce qu'elle réalise dans
ce que vous racontez
combien d'années il faudrait
de budget de soldes positifs au budget
de la france pour arriver à combler la
dette combien d'années mais dites le
nous pour qu'on sache pendant combien de
temps pour la tri mais et vous avez la
même bande de plaisantins qui sont là et
qui coulent dans les dépenses publiques
en espérant que le privé prenne la
relève mais le privé c'est ce que nous
dit notre cher président de la
république monsieur macro et monsieur le
maire qu'un homme sérieux qui croise qui
raconte on est à l'assemblée nationale
je lui dis mais écoutez vous vous devez
de leur faire cadeau 3 milliards d'abord
c'est curieux vous avais rien demandé
mais on n'a pas moi je me rappelle pas
avoir vu une manif de gens avec des
pancartes supprimer l' isf
j'en ai jamais vu une seule fois de ma
vie j'ai juste vu le medef qu'il
réclamait bon vous leur donner 3
milliards parce que vous pensez distille
au mariage était ça dans l'économie très
bien qu'est ce qui vous fait croire que
ces gens là vont réinjecter ces 3
milliards dans l'économie quoi ça aucun
sens pour ça rapporte mois que dans les
lettres du fric dans la sphère
financière réponse de monsieur le maire
elle est admirable elle a été filmée
donc je ne vendent pas il a dit mais
monsieur mélenchon le bon sens donc vous
pensez monsieur le maire monsieur macron
que c'est le bon sens qui anime
l'économie capitaliste moi je crois qu
on est sur quoi là la crise financière
dont on était sûr et la conférence sur
la dette parce que c'est une idée qui
est parti sur l'europe et on était sur
le fait que cette idéologie imaginaire
de gestion des sociétés est en train de
péricliter et que personne ne réagit
comment comment le citoyen lambda doit
s'emparer de ce sujet là c'est le bon
fait pour lui faire qu'on sait le grand
problème des stratégies révolutionnaire
c'est comment
comment on fait pour mais c'est pas la
première fois dans l'histoire de
l'humanité que des gens ont pris des
décisions absurdes jusqu'à en mourir on
en a plein la fin de l'empiré maya c'est
ça des abus sur la nature jusqu'au point
où on en finit par mourir tout ça est
oublié de partir
il ya d'autres exemples comme ça il y en
a plusieurs d'autres des êtres humains
voilà sont des êtres culturels sont des
êtres sociaux mais leurs rapports
sociaux sont culturellement assimilés
c'est comme ça donc les victoires et les
défaites sont culturels quand l'ennemi
réussi à coller dans le crâne de tout le
monde que y'a rien au dessus de la
concurrence libre et non faussée ils
savent le faire et 10 pas vous allez
vous entre détruire ils disent chacun a
sa chance à ces les mecs qui vendent des
billets de loto c'est pareil
voilà 100% des gagnants pour acheter un
billet de loto mais bon
on comprend sa commande comprend ça donc
ils ont réussi à injecter cette idée et
puis vous avez des moments où il se
commande iris déboutonne en ce moment on
est dans une phase
comment dire les libéraux français ont
toujours été ridicule mais cela en ce
moment particulièrement peut-il arriver
après la bataille le monde entier déjà
en train de passer à autre chose et chez
nous on a un président de la république
est un ancien trader et qui fait le kéké
en disant je souhaite que les jeunes
aient envie d'être milliardaire bon
comment peut-on proposer un idéal pareil
obscène
et cruel et violent à la jeunesse comme
personne n'a eue relais à part certain
nombre d'entre nous on en déduit qu'il
ya plein de gens qui sont dit c'est bien
parce que au mois il faut en quelque
chose comme ça alors comment on fait
bon là on entre vraiment dans du
[Musique]
pendant en grand moment on a pensé que
c'était les luttes de la classe ouvrière
qui libérait la société du capitalisme
la vérité c'est que le système
capitaliste produisez lui-même ses
crises en plus des coupes de la
s'accomplir conflictuelle it est avec
les salariés
les crises se resserrant on pouvait
penser que bas à la fin avant de s'en
prendre
les gens réagiraient mais le soft power
1 comme on dit c'est tellement développé
maintenant le contrôle mental sur les
esprits sur les le capitalisme ne sait
pas que le système extérieur à
l'individu cvac une relation sociale un
rapport social c'est un rapport culturel
quand vous prenez une marchandise vous
intégrez son mode d'emploi quand vous
prenez un produit vous intéresse qui
vous intégrer ce qu'il contient tout le
monde sait que par exemple le
capitalisme a normalisé les goûts un jeu
prenant un exemple ce que nous sommes en
france le pinard qui est quand même une
institution essentielle de notre vie
alliant préféré c'est quoi le mien le
saint-amour
gentil j'ai des goûts simples bon
maintenant vous avez le droit
de mettre des copeaux
de bois dans votre tube dans votre cuve
en zinc pourquoi parce que le goût
mondial c'est qu'il ya un fond de bois
vous avez le droit de rajouter du sucre
avant vous aurez couper les mains si
vous faisiez sahin maintenant non
pourquoi parce que le goût a été
mondialisée bourbon et vous pouvez le
vérifier dans d'innombrables domaines
donc le cas de l isi je commencerai dans
notre dans notre corps il est entré dans
nos papilles il entrait dans nos yeux
dans nos oreilles dans notre peau il est
partout c'est comment pour ce vrai
danger commençons d'abord par au moins
nous mettre d'accord là dessus c'est un
non sens bord avant il y avait deux
mondes l'ouest et l'est on pouvait
discuter l'un et l'autre qu'on pouvait
se faufiler au milieu dorel sud ne
voulait pas voir le sud ouest en mai le
jeudi l'est et l'ouest parce que l'est
s'était le système communiste un tiers
de l'humanité a vécu dans un régime
collectiviste jusqu'à l'effondrement de
crédit est super chose ah non
non mais le capitalisme non plus je veux
dire en matière de violations des
libertés de violences contre les
personnes et d'abrutissement collectif
ça y est tu es salaam et vous vous avez
le droit de moi je le pense je la firme
ça se vaut et je vais vous dire plus il
ya une gémellité entre l'ancien système
effondré d'union soviétique et celui des
états unis d'aujourd'hui parce que
l'union soviétique est devenue la russie
et c'est devenu l' empire des oligarques
et d'une forme particulièrement sauvage
de capitalisme mais les états unis
d'amérique se sont jamais débarrassé des
grands appareils de sécurité de lutte
contre les rouges qui ont structuré
toute la vie politique le lobby de
l'armement aux états unis les
tout-puissants 1 je passe sur les autres
lobbys du type pétrole un hamburger
américain que en opposant peu importe
qui sait me dit monsieur mélenchon vous
allez comprendre pourquoi on a un
problème avec le gouvernement s'était
bush à l'époque il me dit est ce que
vous imaginez en france un gouvernement
ou sur 30 membres il y aurait 28
marchand de chaussures
chaussures marchand de chaussures c'est
un métier comme un autre oui c'est un
métier comme un autre 28 bailly chez
nous il ya 28 pétroliers
donc nous sommes dans la main d'une
corporation qui a organisé les relations
internationales sur ce sur la centralité
de l'accès à l'énergie pétrolière était
radicalisation de cette idéologie
alors maintenant les choses évidemment
elle évolue sans cesse les libéraux des
bus paraît de la liberté dans les
grandes enquêtes que l'on fait sur leur
comportement intellectuelle on
s'aperçoit que c'est la caste qui est la
plus hostile à la liberté aujourd'hui
les ceux qui sont le plus certain que la
vérité le bon sens est confiné dans une
catégorie sociale par conséquent ils
sont dangereux alors nous en avons nous
une démonstration nous sommes le seul
pays au monde qui depuis 25 semaines vit
au rythme d'une manifestation
hebdomadaire réprimé avec une sauvagerie
bon qui nous vaut d'être montrée du
doigt par toutes sortes d'organismes
internationaux et des dirigeants
français comme ça scandaleux comme n'ose
mettre en cours je le fait que l'on n'a
pas le droit des borniers 20 personnes
on n'a pas le droit d'en arracher des
marnes à part ça les surprend c'est vous
dire le degré de comme on dit
mithridatisation ça veut dire qu'on
s'habitue et une substance toxique
mithridate s'empoisonner lui-même pour
résister moi g à l'infini mais à petite
dose une belle coups bas on s'habitue
quoi on s'habitue et c'est exactement à
ça qu'on a à faire il faut donc rompre
l'envoûtement
rompre l'envoûtement c'est donc mettre
en oeuvre des stratégies qui permettent
de l'ombre c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous nous avons fait le choix de la
stratégie de la confiture alité c'est à
dire quand tout le monde parlait de
consensus de bon sens et c'est nous nous
expliquions non il n'y a pas de
consensus possible parce que ceci parce
que cela et pendant 7 à 8% dans les
élections européennes ça c'est alors
préciser parce que je sais vous aimez la
précision premièrement ce sont dans les
sondages n'est ce pas donc nous
attendrons faits invoqués du diable 1
commençons par dire ce qui est et
deuxièmement c'est pas 8 mai 9 san
aucune différence pour vous pour nous
sommes à une considérable et puis
troisièmement il faut regarder ce qui
est écrit dedans pourquoi c'est comme ça
c'est intéressant
parce que la masse des gens qui votent
pour nous d'habitude ne veulent pas
voter aux élections européennes parce
qu'il rejette l'europe et ils disent
dans le vent pourquoi j'allais
participer une farce pareil c'est une
erreur totale qu'ils font mais c'est
leur choix et c'est ça qui apparaît dans
tous les sondages
donc à chaque fois que on veut qu'on est
confronté à un phénomène il faut réagir
un matérialiste la question n'est pas
pourquoi mais comment un matérialiste à
toutes les questions pourquoi se pose la
question comment comment se fait-il
qu'on en est là comment se fait-il que
les gens était envoûté comment peut-on
grands pros l'envoûtement on roll
envoûtement avec la stratégie de la
confiture alité l'ennemi c'est comment
faire contre nous jeudi l' ennemi parce
que c'est un ennemi unique il a partout
les mêmes instruments partout les mêmes
arguments de propagande alors il ya
l'ancien vieille propagande de droite
contre les révolutionnaires les
révolutionnaires sont des violents
agressifs
dictatoriaux a toujours été comme ça et
bestiaux
leurs femmes
sont
des personnages bestiaux bestia lisez
aussi les autres jours bestialité et
puis maintenant après ça c'est
sophistiqué c'est pas vous passez à
comment monsieur mélenchon mais vous
êtes le seul millionnaire candidat à
l'élection présidentielle
ils ont raconté ça et le fait-il que ma
déclaration de patrimoine était
supérieure à celle de la milliardaire le
pen à celle de monsieur fillon est tout
bon on m'a acheté ça la figure mais
supposons que je le sois réellement tu
poses on est alors la morale c'est
profiter tétouan est ce que c'est ça la
morale mais pas vous passez à ça marche
pablo iglesias a acheté une maison dans
la banlieue de madrid
d'accord ils ont fait une campagne
pendant 15 jours sur le prix de sa
maison sur le fait qu'il y avait une
piscine est comme ça suffisait pas
ils ont publié les échographies de sa
femme qui était à l'époque enceinte de
jumeaux contre nous tous les coups sont
possibles
la même campagne chez eux chez nous
bestiale is et dénoncer les dirigeants
comme des gens agressif monter des
provoque contre eux
raconter des histoires à dormir debout
comme c'est le cas pour moi avec cette
histoire d'assistants parlementaires du
parlement européen et mes comptes de
campagne j'ai eu beau dire sans foi mais
je suis d'accord pour qu'on examine tous
mes comptes on réexamine ce tout le
monde mais ça vous dérange les autres je
m'en fou juste les miens juste les miens
vous les avez déjà validé j'ai quand
même fait un signalement mais je suis
d'accord regardez les un comité si vous
voulez ce qui est important pour eux
c'est de nous salir pourquoi pour
obtenir que les gens se disent baffe
tout ça c'est tout pareil bah je me
débrouille aujourd'hui on verra bien
demain c'est comme ça qu'ils abrutissent
et là je donne quelques exemples ci
après parce oreste venezuela dont tous
les pays du monde en espagne et en
espagne ils ont fait mieux ils ont piqué
le téléphone de pablo iglesias et avec
le matériel qui avait dedans ils ont
fabriqué des faux pour faire croire que
nos amis de podemos avait touché du fric
du venezuela c'est pas mal non venezuela
pareil pour sanders venezuela pareil
pour
l'anglais
sa rage non faraci l'extrême droite ça
non je parle de
le travailliste à corps bin voila
antisémite il partout jusqu'à l'absurde
sanders est un petit bout dit il au
départ s'est fait traiter d'antisémite
aussi et maintenant tremper les autres
commencent à dire le parti démocrate est
devenue un nid d'antisémite ah voilà les
mêmes arguments les mêmes mots la même
propagande dans le monde entier dans le
monde entier par tous sans exception les
nôtres ont droit aux mêmes campagnes
à mlle andres manuel lopez obrador
actuel président du mexique
ou de la troisième candidature pareil
venezuela cuba cuba venezuela sa maison
sa soeur son frère thomas schaaf tout y
est passé donc pourquoi font-ils ça
parce que leur tactique ce n'est pas de
dire ce que raconte jean luc mélenchon
et ses amis ne tient pas debout il n'en
parlait jamais c'est de détruire la
capacité de confiance que les gens
peuvent avoir en direction de ceux qui
sont dans des situations de rupture en
ce moment nous sommes en campagne
européenne
je fais un truc avec les amis assez
extraordinaire un comité tirés au sort
forme la liste les gens ne sont pas
contents de leur classement s'en
prennent à moi parce qu'ils sont
certains d'avoir un article dans la
presse et une heure de gloire vous avez
des idées des noms des noms qui qui
dijon pas content avec ça à 4-5 je crois
ils ont eu droit à la une du monde la
maison mélenchon cette fissure
trois personnes pas contentes de leur
classement il supporte un mot pour que
ça prenne à moi disent aimer décision
dictatorial j'en prends aucune je ne
mêle pas de cette île après j'ai eu
droit mélenchon a placé son chauffeur
dans la liste je vous jure que c'est
vrai mélenchon a placé son chauffeur
j'ai pas de voiture de fonction je n'ai
pas de voiture du tout comment
pourrais-je avoir un chauffeur revenus
que vous ici en métro non à pied parce
qu'on n'est pas loin mais en général
dans paris circulent en métro et comme
je suis à marseille c'est des copains
qui me fera mal j'ai pas besoin de
chauffeurs après j'ai eu droit mon garde
du corps qu'elle garde du corps chez
aucun système de sécurité on peut me
tuer quand on veut je dis à ceux qui
m'écoutent pense être assez facile parce
que antoine antoine votre ainsi c'est
comme ça il ya quand même eu un malaise
au maghreb qui dit super costaud votre
assistant là il fait quoi 48 kg
je sais pas demandez mais il est
drôlement intelligent parce que c'est le
responsable mais réseau c'est pour ça
qu'il est là parce que c'était un peu
chauffé en 2017 avec lui quand vous nous
avez posé de lapin
commença en 2017 il était entré en
contact avec nous ont été rencontrés en
contact avec lui et vous n'êtes pas
venus qui vous met en contact avec
kinect nous offrait qu'antoine et grecs
antoine thomas antoine c'est autre chose
c'est le responsable des réseaux ça
c'est vos histoires m'ont lancé rien
mais par exemple le coût du garde du
corps c'est quand même énorme et tout ça
pourquoi parce que la presse elle-même
avait dit tiens il ya toujours un type à
côté de mélenchon quand il va dans les
manifs c'est vrai c'est benoît
schneckenburger qui est docteur en
philosophie et professeur de karaté qui
assuré ma protection dans cette
circonstance milite d'abord professeur
de philo militants politiques mais ça a
été transformée et vous avez des
salopards qui prennent ça deux fois
trois fois quatre fois après il ya aussi
le sketch leur doxa elle vous dit en
fait que le monde est infiltré par des
gens qui maîtrisent une idéologie qui
contre la vôtre ah ben oui
vous êtes naïf vous tombez vous sortez
jabra fait l'avocat du diable des
journaux ont une ligne éditoriale
qui correspond à une orientation dents
longues le journal le monde par exemple
et depuis tout le temps lié aux milieux
atlantiste et si vous voulez il faut le
journal le monde ne vous dit pas ce qui
se passe vous disent que vous devez
penser du venezuela de cuba de la
bolivie et à chaque fois pareil je suis
capable de suivre à la trace la bolivie
ils ont commencé par dire que
le président morales n'est pas vraiment
un indien un parce qu'il n'avait pas
vraiment été un des génies s'il avait
été syndicaliste d'accord ils ont
commencé comme ça et puis après ils ont
tapé dessus puis après bon quand les
nord-américains ont décidé que morales
était la bonne gauche et chavez a
mauvaise toux maux a tourné et a trouvé
génial ce qu'ils faisaient et ainsi de
suite amelot pour le mexique les
premiers papiers ont été pour montrer
que bon d'accord il avait gagné d'accord
il avait gagné nettement d'accord il
avait gagné au premier tour ee à 54%
mais quand même il fallait faire
attention que ceux ci et que cela il n'y
a pas eu ligne
marquant le même scepticisme à l'égard
de l'élection du fasciste de la colombie
ou d'autres pays bon alors le monde est
aligné sur le parti démocrate américain
s'est lui même
d'autres journaux sont organisées sur
les conservateurs puis au milieu de tout
ça vous êtes gens font leur métier c'est
à dire qu'ils aiment bien
réputé quoi dire voilà il se passe ici
parce que l'add on tient à nous de
chercher
à trouver notre pitance à travers le les
uns et les autres et du bon journalisme
en france
pardon il reste un bon journalisme un
bon type de journalisme en france un
journalisme qui a un crédit à vos yeux
il ya déjà il ya des journalistes qui
essaye de faire leur boulot
mais vous avez qu à parler avec eux
et vous verrez dans quelles conditions
ça se passe on les connaît pas de soucis
bon ben voilà on le savait tous très
bien comment ça se passe les difficultés
qui ad'abord sais pas est ce que vous
croyez que neuf milliardaire achète 90 %
d'après ce pour le plaisir d'avoir les
journaux gratuits sur leurs tables matin
non ils achètent parce que c'est un
moyen d' influence s'ils ont trop peu
voilà sans doute c'est par philanthropie
amour de la lecture
voilà ils ont acheté tout ça ils font la
loi il pèse comme un couvercle en même
temps il y a une limite à leur pouvoir
et cette limite nous faisons de la voir
par exemple dans la sphère de l'hôpital
la salpêtrière parce que le ministre de
l'intérieur est arrivé alors il ya eu
une attaque contre un hôpital et
services d'urgence aussitôt tous les
larbins sont sortis de la niche en
hurlant 1 est d'abord en tête la radio
d'état la télé d'état tout alors ça
c'est les places et les meilleurs il
faut dire qu'ils se lâchant quand vous
avez un renaud dély qui traite de
vermine les gilet jaune vous avez une
idée de l'ambiance qui règne dans la
salle de rédaction et quand le chef
parle comme ça les autres si on veut
garder sa place au bien manger un bon
alors aussitôt ils ont commencé à
déverser leurs haines et ils ont mis
cinq jours a présenté des excuses aux
gens qu'ils avaient essayé d'induire en
erreur pourquoi l onu même pas vérifié
mois une heure et dix après j'avais déjà
mais un faux
bond et je pense que je suis pas le seul
qui avait des infos pourquoi parce que
nous on vit une vie pas normal on est un
peu à part vous moi mais quand même on
connaît du monde ont peu d'aisance ou
mis en a partout il ya des insoumis chez
les policiers insoumis dans l'hôpital
lens ou lui dans les manifestants nous
sommes plus ou moins liés les uns aux
autres on se prévient en salaires
eux qu'est ce qu'ils font ils sont dans
leur bureau c'est tout en sortent jamais
ces types que vous voyez les
chroniqueurs 1 vous pouvez prendre calvi
a pâti quand est-ce qu'ils vont dans la
rue une seule fois de l'orbit d'abord
maintenant peut plus aller parce que
j'en ai des tests bon mais quand est-ce
qu'ils y vont quand est-ce qu'ils vont
sur le terrain voir une fois parler que
des gens combien d'entre eux a été une
fois sur un rond point zéro jamais ils
sont dans leur bulle un ghetto cher
papier et la chaîne de production de ce
papier qui va lire c'est ça qui nous
intéresse qu'est ce qu'il a écrit et
qu'est ce qu'il a donné à vent
et à partir de quoi il a construit son
récit
ça c'est intéressant parce que d'abord
ça ouvre des brèches ce qu'on parlait
des hackers ça existe aussi dans nom de
papier écrire
c'est très drôle bon ce soir il y en ait
pour prendre on reprend le service a une
grande importance à vous êtes d'accord
parce que les deux piliers de la
démocratie c'est l'école qui vous
apprend à lire à écrire et avoir une
pensée critique et l'information qui
vous permet de vous faire un avis parce
que vous savez pas tout et vous avez
besoin d'être pour prendre notre
question initiale la déradicalisation de
l'idéologie dominante
lala com comment on fait on reprend le
contrôle des médias non alors bon là
vous me je ne peux pas passer des heures
on a eu d'abord beaucoup de débats je
voulais dit tout à l'heure pendant un
temps pensé que cela résultera
des luttes de la classe ouvrière et
beaucoup d'amis continue à penser ça moi
j'ai une autre vision de d'abord il faut
dire qui est l'acteur de l'histoire pour
moi l'acteur de l'histoire c'est ce
qu'on appelle le peuple mais le mot
désigne une réalité qui a changé depuis
les temps où il a été utilisé pour la
première fois au xviie au xviiie siècle
bon le peuple aujourd'hui moi je il ya
deux approches lune qui est que je
considère idéaliste pardon pour ceux qui
n'aiment pas qu'on les assimile à
l'idéalisme philosophie qui consiste à
dire c'est le mécanisme par lequel nous
nous définissons contre e1 c'est un
processus purement idéologique quant à
moi le peuple c'est cette masse de
population
qui a tout changé par sa masse
c'est-à-dire le fait qu'ils aient 7
milliards d'êtres humains change la
nature des relations humaines et qui vit
essentiellement en milieu urbanisé même
quand ils sont à la campagne ça
représente pour les pays comme les
nôtres le 80% de la population dont
l'existence matérielle est déterminé par
l'accès au réseau collectif électricité
eau etc etc éducation santé donc j'ai
une définition matérialise de l'acteur
de l'histoire le peuple et ce peuple est
mis en demeure d'agir pas parce que je
le lui propose de plaisance mis le lui
proposait tout simplement parce que dans
la mise en cause de ses conditions
d'existence il réagi il s'approprie ils
fabriquent une conscience collective
alors il ya des poussées et recule comme
autrefois il y en avait avec eux les
luttes ouvrières donc après à
l'intérieur de cette évidence l'a27 de
cette mouvance là comment on travaille
nous on s'est donné comme objectif
d'être des éclaireurs pas des gens qui
injecte de la conscience mais qui
éclaire le tableau qui partie par des
méthodes d'auto organisation aide à
l'auto organisation populaire et des
déclencheurs voilà ça c'est ce qu'on
appelle le mouvement et j'ai dit une
fois qu'il était gazeuse j'aurais mieux
fait de me taire parce qu'après ça
commence à me prendre à partie sur la
différence entre le gaz liquide enfin
bref c'est pour dire
il faut faire confiance à cette capacité
d'auto organisation de la population
mais soyons clairs c'est encore possible
à l'heure actuelle oui mais la preuve le
mouvement des légendes la preuve c'est
tous les gens qui intellectuellement
sympathise avec ça vous avez vu la
contagion et les 25 pays ou du gilet
jaune c'est incroyable qu'ils en aient
en irak 1 les gens sont censés épauler
pour des histoires de religion et mekla
au mieux qu'harry vaudois attend dé nous
voudrons hôpital public une école etc
c'est à dire la langue universelle et
tabassé aussi ils se sont fait aussi
tabasser toujours certifié attendait
parce que sk lors après qu'est-ce qui va
faire que leur recrutement est rompu ou
pas j'en sais rien nous on appelle ça
les événements fortuits alors c'est une
manière de se réfugier autres du noir
c'est sain bel événement fortuit ça peut
être une nouvelle crise financière
personne contrôle ça éclate faut faire
quelque chose une catastrophe climatique
plus violente qu'une autre un événement
a fait social personne ne pouvait
prévoir que benali tomberait sur le
troisième qui se suicide par le feu dans
son pays la crise qui a qui a éjecté le
pouvoir social démocrate et de droite au
venezuela c'était le prix du ticket de
métro
le chaque fois ce sont c'est un
événement fortuit qui est qui est le
déclencheur 1 et à partir de là se
mettent en route des choses d'une
puissance inouïe il regardait en algérie
bon au départ c'est on en a assez de on
peut pas accepter l'idée qu'on nous
présente comme candidat un président
dont on pense qu'il est peut-être déjà
mort 1 et puis ce truc déclenché une
participation populaire gigantesque et
puis des événements politiques inouïe à
quoi personne ne pensait huit jours
avant et il en sera de même en france et
dans le reste de l'europe ce qu'il faut
donc c'est contribuer de toutes les
façons possibles à élever le niveau de
conscience politique et de pratique
autonome passera bien en france
bon on va succi un petit peu si je vous
dis intelligence artificielle
reconnaissance faciale contrôle des
réseaux
je suis comme tout le monde à ses black
mirror ça me fait peur
adebayor est en train de regarder la
série on a beau demander de fixe oui
oui alors bon je dis ça pour parce que
comme ça ça ça crée du lien entre ceux
qui m'écoutent et conduit le regarder
mais enfin vous savez j'ai été très
amateur de sur ses fonctions
dans les années
70-80 j'en ai un mur jt des quantités
considérables je vous dis cela hiver je
les ai vu le film bien sûr c'est même
lui qui a formé la conscience écologique
de mes enfants
est-ce qu'on ait à se livrer en ce
moment est-ce qu'on a une fuite en avant
du capitalisme ben on n'est pas un
soleil d'hiver parce que vous n'y vas y
vas oui parce que deux milliards et demi
si vous voulez il ya une constante dans
l'histoire je fais partie des gens
qu'ils ont discerné domblans suis pas
peu fier chaque fois que l'humanité
double en nombre l ai fait un saut dans
une réorganisation générale de ses
moyens
la double chaque fois ils play triple
chaque fois comme moi je suis né
souhaitait le millier d'individus qu'il
y en a sept aujourd'hui c'est à dire
qu'on a triplé tout on fait comme si
s'était rien passé tout l'art est de
faire des bébés ou pas
ça je crois que ça se fait tout seul
pour l'instant à bientôt ça sera plus
mais pour l'instant ça fonctionne encore
tout seul mais je vais vous donner un
exemple
par exemple si je vous dis au
néolithique on est passé de la chasse à
l'élevage bon
c'est un événement quand même on est
d'accord ou bien on est passé de la
cueillette à l'agriculture c'est un
événement aussi bien figurez-vous qu'en
2013 on a un événement comparable
on a mangé plus de poissons d'élevage
queue de poisson pêché dans la mer
poissons sauvages autrement dit on est
passé de la cueillette à l'élevage ça
s'est passé en 2013
exemple de saut de changements
fondamentaux
il y en a comme ça à plat et tout
commence au monde ah ça commence en 1950
et à partir de là toutes les courbes
sont comme ça de prédation sur la nature
de production de l'énergie de 1750
c'est une transition vous prenez pas là
l'aspect accès à l'énergie
l'accès charbon l'axé pétrole vous vous
corrélés passe à la fonction
exponentielle de croissance je le corps
est là aux événements qui ont été
contemporain je vous indique seulement
qu'il ya une date à partir de laquelle
le niveau des prédations change et donc
la nature des relations sociales change
vous fait pas vivre trois milliards de
personnes connectées par internet de la
même manière qu'à l'époque où on s'est
envoyé des lettres vous le savez aussi
bien que moi peut-être que vous êtes
d'une génération qui a jamais connu le
courrier écrit les timbres et tout ça si
on a connu des biens jeunes bon c'est
quand même une affaire qui a maintenant
plus de trente ans non combien vous
diriez vous oui simple tu entends le
mail le mail non le mels 1,20 en bois 20
ans donc ça va vous avez pu connaître la
période où on s'envoyait des cartes de
voeux dont faisait de la radio à
l'époque ouais bah j'en ai fait
j'adorais ça on était une radio pirate
bas au début c'était pirates
et puis après on a légalisé tout ça mais
dans la période de 7 et pirates il y
avait un côté
libre
on s'est fait des illusions quoi on
était persuadé que si tout le monde
pouvait faire sa radio le foisonnent ray
je sais pas quoi et puis alors à
l'énorme déception on a fait plein de
radio qui on a découvert que ce qu'ils
montaient c'était ce qu'il y ait là
descendez avant quoi donc les copains
qui avaient des radios libres à un
moment donné la fédération dont je
m'occupais dans mon département avec 5
passes et de la musique des débats la
noix les
est-ce que youtube c'est les nouvelles
radios pirates
away de toute façon alors là moi je
parle comme un militant politique un pas
comme un sociologue même si j'ai
quelques idées en sociologie et en
anthropologie
pour un militant politique le devoir
c'est d'être toujours à la pointe des
techniques de communication et d'échangé
un devoir c'est vous devez savoir faire
marcher tout ça donc youtube pour
l'instant les chaînes whatsapp se lécher
le télégramme les chaînes signal c'est
faux faux faux savoir alors la halle en
ce moment la situation en train de
tourner et vous l'avez peut-être vu
watsa pas à couper le compte de podemos
la dernière semaine des élections
législatives
whatsapp égale facebook d'accord donc on
est en train de se préparer on n'a pas
eu le temps d'en parler encore on va on
va préparer le la riposte c'est à dire
s'il nous coupe comme on est là le
lendemain donc pour l'instant mon idée
c'est que d'abord il faut faire muter le
plus de monde possible sur télégramme
parce que c'est censé être au russe alla
au pour nous couper tout de suite mais
on aurait la possibilité on ne faut pas
mettre tous nos oeufs dans le même
panier
parce que le mouvement 1 en tant que
mouvement politique france insoumise il
repose à 80% sur sa plateforme et sur
ces réseaux sociaux
donc si on nous coupe tout est coupé on
trouvera en survivra je préviens ceux
qui nous regardent et qui auraient des
idées malveillantes l'hypothèse dans
laquelle on cesse le combat n'existe pas
donc vous pouvez rentrer ce que vous
voulez ça continuera mais on est obligé
de tenir compte de ça la dernière
semaine quick
plus doux à sap cinquante mille
personnes d'un coup sans contact pour
podemos alors bon nous il faut qu'on
tienne compte de ça parce que la raison
à vous quitter quoi
que il faisait une utilisation
commerciale qui n'était pas vouée
bon une embrouille de ce type là alors
évidemment pour demos a immédiatement
répliqué en montrant que le psoe parti
socialiste ouvrier espagnol faisait la
même chose et que molson arrow avait
fait pire est que personne n'avait rien
demandé donc on voit on comprend que
c'est nous qui prenons quoi mais
voilà c'est vraiment les tendances les
plus inquiétants on va repasser la
politique internationale et le venezuela
bull venezuela il se passe quoi là c'est
un coup à prendre
vous allez sûrement m'interroger sur
quelque chose rêve à les lire je vous
pose la question ouais c'est un coup
d'état c'est un putschiste en face à
d'accord à duroux il est comment il
moqué de long il a fait que des bonnes
choses tout va bien qu'est ce qui se
passe ou yb a déjà tout va bien c'est
une bonne question ça me semble bien
correspondre à la situation est ce que
j'ai le choix entre tout va bien et tout
est pourri mondiale qui a des nuances
possibles on peut faire savoir annonce
du jeu se passe-t-il au venezuela le
venezuela a fait une révolution
populaire
dont on peut discuter le contenu pour
savoir si elle a été assez loin
notamment dans les rapports de propriété
est-ce qu'elle a été assez loin dans la
bonne compréhension
de
de la nécessité de sortir des énergies
carbonées mais quand vous êtes la
première réserve de pétrole du monde
c'est un peu compliqué
bon nous ils sont pas tenus à leur place
c'est à dire que ils ont distribué le
pognon à tout le monde ils ont pas fait
comme les monarchies pétrolières qui
elles sont éminemment respectable bon
cette année ils ont décapité quarante et
une personnes ont crucifié une mais bon
ce sont des gens respectables parce
qu'il garde le fric pour chavez a
partagé ça c'était la période chavez et
au lieu de rester tranquille dans son
coin il a commencé à aider tout le monde
les autres pays a essayé de monter des
mouvements progressistes et des
révolution bolivarienne un peu comme qui
a deux filles
je sais pas j'ai pas suivi je sais pas
ce que faisait kadhafi s'était pas monde
possible je sais pas je sais pas je sais
pas pourquoi vous pensez à kadhafi vous
pourriez penser à cuba cuba socialiste a
aidé beaucoup de monde
bon
alors
à partir de là c'était trop pour les
nord-américains d'abord la première
réserve de pétrole allaient à leur porte
elle est pas en arabie saoudite elle est
là au venezuela 18 % du pétrole consommé
par les gens à la pompe vient du
venezuela
donc venezuela est un enjeu stratégique
pour les états unis d'amérique il faudra
apporter la démocratie
pardon il faut leur apporter la
démocratie au venezuela ah pardon
au venezuela apparemment il s'est
débrouillé tout seul
pour s'inventer leur forme mais bon on a
voté du temps de chavez 14 fois
aucun soin on a perdu une fois
il ya perdu un référendum il a reconnu
qu'il ait perdu aucune des 14 soit n'a
été mis en cause par les organismes
internationaux
localement la droite est passé d'une
attitude
putschistes super agressif parce que
j'aurai rappeler qu'il ya eu un putsch
contre chavez c'est à dire qu'il a été
enlevé arrêté qui la liait de fusiller
il a été tirée d'affaires parce que le
peuple de caracas est descendue dans les
rues et que les militaires ont dit nous
on exécute pas ce type
il ya un problème avec sa démocratie au
venezuela bien sûr pas un seul des
putschistes de l'époque n'a été en
prison nous en france on a eu un pool
tchèque les généraux en algérie sont
restés 25 ans ont trop
au venezuela 0 même pas en moi même pas
un jour ils ont tous signé un papier un
premier temps qu'il recommencerait pas
voilà donc c'est vous dire que le roman
racontée par les américains et la
réalité ces deux choses alors ensuite
malheureusement hugo chavez est mort
il ya un bilan du chavisme moi je peux
pas juger le bilan économique du
chavisme parce que je suis pas assez
pointues pour ça et puis peut-être que
je serais pas d'accord avec l'importance
donnée à l'industrie pétrolière mais je
comprenais ce qu'ils faisaient
puis ça n'existe pas une comme c'est
nous c'est il faut qu'on soit 100%
parfait pure technique bord au poids les
hôtels des capi qui tua moitié des gens
meurent de faim on s'en fout parce que
c'est la liberté vous comprenez monsieur
tandis que bonds de chavez non alors on
regarde et l'arrêtent pas te parle à la
télé depuis le montre a fait mieux 1
macron et puis tous les autres appareils
qu'ils soient de droite ou de gauche et
l'amérique latine donc il ya un roman de
diabolisation du chavisme je me rappelle
d'une page de libé c'est moi c'est comme
ça que je suis entré en contact vraiment
politique et de chavistes une page de
libé il y avait j'avais les mains comme
ça à regarder au ciel il était marqué le
credo antisémite de chavez
mois les antisémites j'ai jamais aimé
100 d'accord donc qu'est-ce que je fais
mon corps et du fer les journalistes
n'ont
qu'à aller voir mais attends tu peux pas
y aller pas grave tu prends le téléphone
et appelle le président de la communauté
juive de caracas c'est ce que j'ai fait
et je dis j'arrive fonctionner le voir
et je lui dis maintenant
je vous pose la question c'est est un
type formidable comment il s'appelle
j'ai oublié son nom mais faisait des
chemises bon alors on a un peu blague et
je crois d'ailleurs saisi chemise
lacoste un truc français donc il était
europhile pardon leur fils francophile
un don qu'il nous aimait beaucoup tout
ça bon alors enfin bon on n'était pas du
même bord politique que moi je dis alors
chavez il me dit je dis voilà il se dit
qu'il est antisémite qui dit écoutez il
a tous les défauts alors tout y est
passé 1 mais pas celui là
jeudi pour moi c'est très important
parce que si pour vous c'est un
antisémite moi je suis avec vous ou pas
etc lui
ce type m'a paru d'une d'une honnêteté
c'était pas son intérêt il aurait pu me
raconter des trucs pour me remémorer la
tête et je lui suis très reconnaissant
de ça alors après évidemment libé avait
à raconter des bêtises sur la base d'une
traduction de fera là des trucs
c'était une phrase parce que chavez
parler interminablement comme moi même
et très vite chavez est très chrétien
non mais c'est soulant quoi personne
n'est parfait un fouet et ça fait partie
de leur truc la théologie de la
libération a été l' idéologie commune de
tous les deux tout les dirigeants
progressistes mais qu'il y avait en
particulier était beaucoup dans
l'emphase
religieuse une année où il a été élu et
la deuxième fois et je trouve que
j'étais là il pleuvait comme le vache
qui pisse delà de vous savez la flotte
des caraïbes quoi dégoût de grosses
comme ça est toute chaude alors dont été
noyés sous la flotte et me parlait
parlait alors il disait je vois le
christ libérateur le christ commandant
des peuples est bon autour les copains
rigoler parce qu'ils connaissent eux mes
convictions laïques donc presque à
supporter un prêt de francs d'entendre
ce discours les bocaux et raconter tout
ça il pas curé et président de la
république culturel disent oh c'est
normal mais lui non enfin il trouvait ça
normal et il était il faisait souvent
des analogies avec la religion
chrétienne et alors ils disaient ce
qu'ils ont
crucifié le christ oui pacifier le
christ et simon bolivar je ne crois pas
un truc bon alors diard c'est la thèse
chrétienne des juifs comme crise
électrique pour fêter pas de pauvres
personne personne a crucifié simon
bolivar c'était une phrase et à partir
de là il est fait tout une mousse mais
moi je suis heureux de ça parce que je
suis entré dans la lutte et j'ai
commencé à m'intéresser à eux parce que
j'en fait l'aveu il m'intéressait pas
parce que moi au chavez c'est un ancien
militaire espace est pas ma culture moi
j'étais fasciné par le parti des
travailleurs du brésil par lula c'était
ça qui me semblait
je me suis trompé donc j'ai découvert la
révolution bolivarienne les techniques
de combat politique de chavez avec
l'idée comme ils disaient que je crée
pas un parti révolutionnaire jcr un jeu
j'ai du camp peuple révolutionnaire ça
m'a frappé et ça m'a marqué samar maféré
péché mon copie pas et j'en dis assez
votre modèle forcément
on a là des gens des créatures de
bureaux dans les rédactions que jamais
rien vu qui parle avec personne que rien
intéresse donc ils pensent que comme
quoi ils copient les émissions des
américains est compilé des copies non
pas d'imagination ils n'ont pas d'idées
donc ça leur dit rien il croit qu'on
qu'on imite un modèle non on s'inspire
moi j'ai toujours dit je n'ai pas de
modèle c'est une source d'inspiration
moi je ne ferais pas on m'a dit vous
voulez faire le venezuela france mais
ils sont bêtes à manger du foin le v10
voilà en france comment c'est possible
on n'a pas de pétrole comment je fais un
modèle économique qui soit celui du
venezuela ça tient pas debout j'ai
jamais voulu faire ça mais je me suis
inspiré ce qui pesé oui beaucoup sur la
méthode politique à essentielle ment pas
sur l'économie
parce qu'en vérité si on entrait dans
les détails j'aurai avec eux des
divergences mais je peux pas me
permettre de faire ça si je commence à
dire que j'ai des divergences on a plus
parlé que de ça c'est pareil pour cuba
par exemple bombe à cuba moi j'ai
rappelé j'ai toujours eu un rapport
critique
au système politique cubain mais que ce
soit le venezuela comme pour cuba le
point numéro un c'est pas d'embargo pas
d'intervention militaire voilà les
sanctions ça ne fonctionne pas ah ben si
ça fonctionne et sanctions mais ça
fonctionne très bien ça fout ne merde
pas croyable ça désorganise toute
l'économie
ça fonctionne très bien et si les
peuples qui morfle mais le peuple
vénézuélien comme le peuple cubain
faudra lille débusquer rue par rue parce
que là la gare d'eau et compagnie là qui
ont fait les clowns depuis deux mois en
poussant tout le monde je ne sais quoi à
faire un coup d'état c'est ça qu'il a
essayé d'organiser ce type sort de son
pays va chez le voisin appelle
l'intervention militaire d'un autre pays
fait une comédie avec une espèce de
convois humanitaires at il eu même fou
feu pour remonter la provocation il
rentre au venezuela personne n'oserait
même pas une amende pour dire propos
excessifs tu vois comme en france on
fera un jour public ça existe un rien
que dalle y rentrer il sort un autre qui
en résidence surveillée qu'un vrai
fachos qui a personnellement attaqué
l'ambassade de cuba à caracas qui a
personnellement jeté des cocktails
molotov que nous trouvons délicieux ici
quand ils sont jetés là bas quand c'est
ici c'est une autre paire de manches
donc tous ces gens qui sont qui ont mis
le paquet avec l'aide de 50 pays du
monde dont le président macron qui ont
reconnu un putschiste comme chef de
l'état autoproclamé
ils l'ont reconnu et où ils en sont
aujourd'hui 1 où ils en sont où l
insurrection militaire et populaire
l'autre jour il y avait plus de
journalistes que d'opposants devant les
casernes ils ont perdu pourquoi parce
que le peuple ait pas d'accord le peuple
pas content de ce qui vit ça c'est sûr
je les connais les vénézuéliens en plus
c'est des gens des caraïbes faut jamais
perdre ça de vue
c'est peut-être du rhin et puis pas
facile a pas facile ils veulent pas être
les agents des américains et aider des
fachos qui viennent des beaux quartiers
de caracas à prendre le pouvoir
retourner à comme avant à être des
animaux non ils veulent pas alors sans
doute qu'ils rénovent alors d'ailleurs
une partie de l'opposition vénézuélienne
de droite fait pas partie des
putschistes monsieur capri l'aise c'est
un nom qui ne dira rien en france mais
il a quand même été candidat deux fois
l'élection présidentielle pour la droite
ce que la droite au venezuela faut la
voir ça va des socialistes à l'extrême
droite la plus bestial c'est ça la
droite du venezuela bon ben ya des gens
là dedans qui disent oui bon d'accord on
s'oppose mais
c'est la démocratie quoi pas des coups
de fusil pas les batailles rangées dans
la rue et le reste pour cela ils sont
pas d'accord avec le putsch et fait
revenir les américains alors ils sont
tous là dire oui mais la situation
économique est épouvantable très bien
lever l'embargo ça ira déjà un peu mieux
si vous trouvez que ça va si mal que ça
quelle est la réponse de monsieur pompeo
le proconsul général pour l'amérique du
sud de l' empire c'est de dire les rues
joffre partira bon parce que les russes
et les russes le problème maintenant
aussi au venezuela en fin de fait tout
cela est absurde alors bon
qu'est-ce qu'est ce que je peux dire sur
le venezuela on attend de moi que je
critique critiquerai pas je le ferai pas
a dit vous soutenez le venezuela ge ge à
dire le v10 qu'est ce que c'est que
cette histoire je regarde d'abord suis
français et pas qu'un peu
donc je regarde j'apprends déjà
premièrement je me prends pas pour le
centre du monde comme tous les européens
au centre est dès que ça lui en amérique
latine il considère tout ça comme un
ramassis d'indigènes claude rich et
s'intéresse pas à ce qu'ils font mais ce
qu'ils font est très intéressant et ça
nous permet de vérifier des hypothèses
dans affirmé dans confirmé de ce qui
marche qui marchent parce qu'il faut pas
faire ce qu'il faut apprendre d'eux on a
plein de choses à apprendre d'eux dans
tous les domaines alors c'est vrai que
sur le plan économique
je me sentais plus proche de rafael
correa mais ça vous savez je sais pas
pourquoi je vous dis ça parce que ça
sert à rien ce n'est qu'hier rien mais
moi ça permet de dire que j'aimais bien
la manière avec laquelle
rafael correa avait pris la question du
redéploiement des infrastructures
en equateur bon j'ai trouvé plus plus
brouillonne la méthode vénézuélienne
mais je suis pas assez connaisseur je
m'interdis de dire il faut faire ci ou
il faut faire ça ce que je peux dire
c'est je ne serais pas d'accord avec
l'intervention militaire je ne suis pas
d'accord avec les putschistes et à
choisir entre monsieur garrido et
monsieur le président nicholas maduro je
suis plutôt pour monsieur maduro ce qui
ne veut pas dire que je le bénis que je
l'en semble que tout ce qui fait génial
mais d'abord il est élu quoi enfin
accepter les résultats de l'élection de
brasse outil on va switcher l'écologie
ou nucléaire ici
d'interconnecter seul et a vu leur
l'année passée 9 heures du soir je suis
arrivé à 7 heures
c'est l'heure de l'apéro ces noms là le
l'écologie oui
on est sur un système financier qui est
basé sur une fonction exponentielle on
dit que l'écologie font rentrer en phase
de décroissance parce que on peut plus
imposer une charge très importante à
notre biotope le système financier va
pas pouvoir tenir la route qu'est ce
qu'on fait avec l'écologie on fait un
capitalisme de convenance un capitalisme
écologique comment ça marche
l'écologie c'est en termes trop générale
il faut qu on parle de la crise de
l'écosystème parce que non mais ça
change tout aussi longtemps qu'on a cru
les uns et les autres qu'on était dans
une crise graduelle il y avait un type
de réponse possible on pouvait imaginer
d'ailleurs des stratégies réformiste
beaucoup plus lente 1 pour faire la
transition écologique là les types nous
disent vous avez douze ans après savoir
c'est pas vrai autant qu'on nous le dise
mais si c'est vrai vous peut-être se
bouger le la sixième extinction moi
j'avais lu le bouquin de lisabeth colère
je trouvais ça
quand je les lui je me suis dit ouf ça
fait beaucoup bon bah c'est vrai donc on
est maintenant dans un autre rapport à
l'urgence et dans l'urgence au fond
d'abord commençons par dire une chose
pratiquement tous les partis maintenant
sont écologie sont en tout cas essaye de
lettres nom n'a pas droit de leur jeter
des pierres parce que l'europe écologie
les verts aimeraient bien avoir le
tampon pour distribuer les brevets mais
pardon mais c'est pas à eux c'est fini
maintenant cette époque là
on est dans une autre époque donc ce
qu'ils se confrontent c'est la méthode
pour régler la crise
donc il ya les méthodes qui consistent
qui considère que le marché l'écologie
de marché possible le marché va mettre
des clips nous nous pensons que les gens
comme moi pensent que c'est impossible
le la réponse à la crise écologique ne
passe pas par la libre compétition par
le marché parce que le marché ne peut
réguler que des intérêts particuliers
qui sont par nature sans destination
particulière un donkament oro ça veut
pas dire immoraux amoraux à écologique à
tout ce que vous voulez sauf la logique
du profit donc à nos yeux c'est un
système d'économie mixte c'est-à-dire
comportant les droits du secteur privé
et les droits du secteur public qui lui
doit imposer la planification écologique
et l'intérêt général
ma position non c'est pas très compliqué
ça règle la question d'ailleurs de là
bas non c'est pas très compliqué moi
j'ai pas mis dans mon programme qu'on
allait tout nationaliser bon alors là si
on nationalise pas tout on peut
peut-être discuter de de la façon dont
tous petits monstres bon là et conduit à
vivre ensemble
d'abord vous êtes obligé de faire appel
à la technique là où elle existe à nous
on a la chance parce qu'on a du monde
pour faire sage que l'état de pays comme
le venezuela où on pouvait décider ce
qu'on voulait et personne pour le faire
donc il y avait quand même un problème
bon nous on a tout le monde
l'économie mixte ça veut dire que par
exemple certains secteurs doivent être
nationalisées par exemple que la
puissance publique va intervenir avec
son fric pour développer certaines
productions qui va falloir bosser c'est
pour ça que le thème croissance
décroissance est assez complexe à gérer
parce que certaines activités vont
mécaniquement croître par exemple si
nous décision nous décidons et il faut
le faire de fermer les 59 réacteurs
nucléaires de notre pays va faire
comment pour respecter le bilan carbone
si on ferme notre justice notre
industrie et ben c'est la raison pour
laquelle il faut que les énergies
alternatives soit exploité à fond les
ballons c'est à dire la géothermie c'est
à dire l'éolien en mer parce que à terre
faut voir les problèmes que cela pose
j'ai pris la 7 de sources y en a
d'autres à la biomasse tous après il ya
plein de sources mais il faut pas
commencer à discuter interminablement et
blabla t il comme quand on est on
économise guerre on dit ben voilà on a
tant d'années on va fermer toutes les
centrales nucléaires dans tel délai
bombes allaient pour y aller faut y
aller il faut produire faut sortir les
pales pour les éoliennes faut être
capable d'allaiter plein air pourront
faire des bateaux mais ça fait combien
ça coûte deux femmes et un réacteur
écoutez je peux vous dire ce que ça
coûte de le re re caréné d'accord 150
milliards vous choisissez 150 milliards
pour re caréné le nucléaire la totalité
du parc vous les mettez dans le grand
carénage ou dans les énergies
alternatives choisissez moi j'ai choisi
les énergies alternatives
mais bon c'est ma manière d'être moi je
crois aux planches quoi alors le plan et
s'évanouissent mon dieu le plan le
gosplan aussitôt qui parle du plan c'est
le gosplan à l'union soviétique
car à massy d'ignorants qui sait pas que
tout le monde à planifier toutes les
économies et les économies capitalistes
ont planifié pendant des années la
reconstruction et je suis obligé de le
redire qu'elle continue à planifier
aujourd'hui mais aujourd'hui ça
s'appelle plus planification s'appelle
gestion prévisionnelle la même chose on
switch sur un autre sujet parce que
leur avancée a ouais c'est clair puis
j'ai faim se sont tout ça on ira se
prénomme titre qu'après les migrants
n'ont fait quoi
de de quoi vous parlez les réfugiés
climatiques les migrants économiques
organise à il ya deux choses à faire
la première c'est que les gens a pas
besoin de partir de chez eux c'est le
plus important
c'est l'attitude rationnelle si vous
pensez que c'est pas une bonne chose que
des gens se déplacent par millions
le la meilleure façon de faire c'est
qu'il sait qu'il reste la wii sont parce
que là où ils sont il ya du commerce il
ya de l'industrie de l'agriculture etc
ont fait le contraire et attendait mais
on le fait d'une manière sauvage total 1
pendant tout le monde blablate l'europe
passent des accords avec des pays sur la
pêche par exemple ils achètent à
l'avance la pêche dit pas c'est que les
bateaux vont ramasse tous les gens qui
sont là au bord qui vivaient de la
petite pechoux y tous les jours mon
regret piraterie bon là quatre pirates
rinne on la combat en mer mais les gens
qui faisaient ça bah ils peuvent plus
vivre et je prends cet exemple parce que
c'est en train de se passer en ce moment
les grands moralisateurs sur l'europe
près de poètes et le reste ça qu'ils
sont en train de faire c'est ça leur
europe 1 alors bon donc que les gens et
pas besoin de partir deuxio
qu' un certain nombre d'européens
arrête de
se rengorger à réfléchir un peu il pense
aux gens qui arrivent du sud mon dieu
mais des gens de chez nous qui partent
qu'est ce qu'on leur dit le dis ça pour
un certain nombre de mes amis
qui considère que ma position une fois
que j'ai eu dix il vaut mieux que les
gens partent pas de là où ils sont c'est
une position qui n'est pas acceptable
pour une certains secteurs de la vieille
gauche un bon alors je leur dis avant
elle c'est une chance peut-être dont
vous avez qu à les lire oruma 20% de la
population a dû partir qu'est ce qui se
passe on y fils on y attendait parce que
vous allez voir je prends l'exemple de
des roumains parce qu'il m'intéresse
parce que les romains 8 sont ils sont
dans les autres pays les nôtres d'accord
en train de travailler des fois ce
statut de travailleurs détachés quand il
faut faire quelque chose en roumanie
comment ils font les gars ils sont plus
et ben qu'est-ce qu'ils font des
travailleurs des péchés ukrainiens parce
qu'ils coûtent 130 euros par mois c'est
ça le smic histoire de chou parce que
alors les gens par d'un endroit à
l'autre tout le monde est malheureux
c'est tout voilà la seule chose que ça
donne c'est du malheur on parle de 800
mhz y on parle de 500 milles espagnol va
falloir un peu atterrir là le la
principale cause de départ c'est les
conditions sociales ces grecs espagnols
et ces roumains ne sont pas partis pour
faire pour améliorer leurs connaissances
d'une langue étrangère il en va de même
des gens du sud maintenant quand les
gens sont là quand ils ont passé le
martyre d'arriver jusqu'à nous on a un
devoir d'humanité et d'accueil
humain et respectueux d'accord voilà on
fait comme ça on rejette pas les gens à
la mer on le fera pas qu'on les laisse
pas mourir dans le plus grand cimetière
du monde qu'est la mer méditerranée
qu'on est en train de le faire et pour
le reste c'est une quantité de gens qui
est infime et que nos sociétés sont
parfaitement capables d'absorber mais
vous savez on est mal parti parce que
quand je vois le comportement des gens à
l'égard par exemple des populations du
maghreb avec lesquels on vit on n'a même
plus droit de le dire
quand on parle de l'algérie par exemple
en france il ya trois millions personnes
qui sont pieds noirs fils et petits
enfants les pieds noirs il ya trois
millions et demi de binationaux donc
quand vous dites le mot algérie il ya
six millions et demi de personnes dans
ce pays pour qui ça immédiatement on
tend l'oreille il n'ya pas de peuple
avec lequel on est davantage intriqués
qu'avec le peuple algérien je pourrais
faire une remarque sans doute similaire
pour les marocains et peut-être pour les
tunisiens et on se comporte comme si
tout ça nous concerne est pas comme si
nous n'avions pas ensemble des enfants
des cousins des tatas d'être honteux
c'est un comportement de déni de la
réalité qui est absurde la question
qu'on doit se poser c'est comment on
continue à faire france de tout bois
comment on continue à être un peuple un
et indivisible
voilà et bien pour ça la première
réponse est tout le monde à l'école
tout le monde est bien traitée à l'école
deuxio tout le monde est bien traité
quand il est malade et ainsi de suite la
langue universelle il faut la parler
entre nous voilà alors sur les migrants
après le reste c'est des phrases
ce qui me saoule avec l'arc de l'extrême
droite cette fois ci alors ils sont avec
les clandestins fera ça c'est toujours
le grand sujet comment vous répondez à
savoir et l abord le vous répondent en
rien à combien
on sait pas mais sans doute eu cent
mille comme on s'en doute puissant milou
vous savez pas comment vous savez que
sans doute ses 800 milles je suis
entendu ça dans des débats alors les
autres disent non c'est 200 milles ceux
qui veulent réduire le taux du bon lait
on coupe la poire en deux 400000
supposons qu'ils aient quatre cent mille
clandestins dans ce pays alors vous
faites quoi vous leur corps est derrière
très bien ça va vous mobiliser du monde
et comment vous faites pour reconnaître
un clandestin dedans qu'il n'est pas
allé surtout pas juger sur leur mina
parce que vous allez commettre des
erreurs terribles les français y en a de
toutes les couleurs de toutes les
apparences de toutes les religions alors
donc vous finissez par les capturer
je peux vous les mettez et puis après
vous les ramenez chez de très bien à
bonne idée c'est où chez eux donc
combien d'endroits combien de trains
combien d'avions
tout ça c'est des histoires ça n'a pas
le début du commencement d'une réalité
concrète à part gueuler et empoisonner
la vie de tout le monde ce genre de
débats ne nous mène nulle part parce que
si tout le monde avait du travail si le
logement social et est facilement
accessible
si on se transporte facilement
personne ne verrait de problèmes avec
les uns avec les autres alors certains
pratiquent la religion d'une manière
tellement ostentatoire que ça agace mais
je le comprends parfaitement c'est pas
une raison pour aller leur faire la
guerre j'ai connu - une période où il y
avait des sort dans la rue et qui
échappe aux accords net il y avait des
gars qui avaient dès le début comme on
appelait ça la
vous savez la tenue des curés avant ce
truc la soutane voilà un bon et alors ça
a énervé les incroyants et d'un bon on a
réglé ça on est arrivé à vivre ensemble
bon on fait quoi que le terrorisme
d'abord on commence par être précis
pour éviter de dire des bêtises
le terrorisme ça n'a pas de sens ce sont
les actes terroristes qui existe
qu'est-ce qu'on fait face aux actes
terroristes
on les combat on pourchasse ceux qui les
commettent
et on tâche de s'en débarrasser
toujours pas ce qu'on peut dire d'autre
est-ce qu'on arrête de nous rentrer
est-ce qu'on arrête nos relations
internationales avec ceux qui financent
le terrorisme
ah bah il vaudrait mieux on peut aussi y
avoir des mesures de rétorsion moins
spectaculaire mais aussi efficace on
peut pas accepter
de faire comme si on ne savait pas la
contribution de particulière de l'arabie
saoudite au financement d'un certain
terrorisme du qatar dans certains autres
et ainsi de suite je pense qu'on est en
droit de se demander
des explications de ne pas accepter que
nous soyons
le chant de guerre de tous ces gens là
et puis après évidemment faut faire
attention à ce qu'on fait parce que
c'est pas la peine d'y multiplier
parce que qui est ce qui fait d acte
terroriste alors les barjots les gens
fous
fous alors bon on leur fait faire
quelque chose
ce qui les anime d'aller contrôler de
cette manière là
mais on fait aussi là je parle d'acte
terroriste 1 mais
certaines bandes armées sont d'abord
constitué par le fait qu' on a laissé
des situations dégradées par exemple
autour du lac tchad le fait que le lac
se soit guidée du fait de l'usagé qu'on
en a fait avec toutes les populations
qui avaient autour fournissent le gros
de la troupe mercenaires qui est utilisé
par des structures
politico militaire comme boko haram et
ainsi de suite pour lequel la religion
est un prétexte en bon
donc
en france on fait comme en france on
fait comment en france pour neutraliser
les ce qu'ils appellent les poches du
terrorisme les poches de terrorisme
radicaux les machins et ben on fait
comment mais vous êtes incroyables on
fait comment et comme ta connerie on
fait comment on n'avait pas demandé
contre la bêtise un signe
concédé quand même avec le capitalisme
alors
c'est vrai non pas au combat
on dé quoi on descend avec des voitures
on va les chercher où les métaux sur
écoute on fait quoi mais on fait tout ça
monsieur déjà
ça va fonctionner ah bon pourquoi il ya
un attentat tous les jours vous trouvez
que ça fonctionne pas la fonction de
très bien ça fonctionne du mieux que ça
peut fonctionner mais dans cette
situation il y aura jamais 100% de
sécurité est-ce que c'est pas un peu du
ramassage scolaire que de 2,2 tout
filtrer et d'inciter ceux à passer
encore plus sous le radar les plus
agressifs les plus
c'est la ville peut insérer une
sélection darwinienne par l'algorithme
combat ce que vous voulez me dire moi ce
que je veux juste dire c'est que ceux
qui font ça vous est venu pardon je peux
vous expliquer différemment si vous
voulez non mais je ne suis pas d'accord
pour entrer dans ce d'abord du ramassage
scolaire des expressions pareil le
ramassage scolaire c'est une activité
tout à fait pacifique est gentil faut
pas faire des comparaisons qui a on a
affaire à un certain nombre de gens
il y avait moyen peut-être d'être plus
efficace pour les empêcher de partir
parce qu'il faut jamais que vous oubliez
que ça a été une souffrance terrible
pour les familles qui ont vu les enfants
partir dans ce genre d' aventure
surtout quand c'est au nom d'une
religion que souvent la famille partage
mais dont elle n'est pas d'accord d'en
voir une pratique pareil
ne croyez pas que
les parents qui ont vu
ou qu'ils ont appris que leur enfant
était temps belga départ des jeux couper
des têtes elle reste est pensé que
c'était une activité qui était conforme
à l'idée qu'ils se faisaient de leur
religion donc faut y aller quand même un
peu doucement on n'est pas dans un jeu
vidéo on n'est qu'avec des gens humains
vivant qu'est ce que vous voulez qu'on
fasse d'autre
de combattre ceux qui se préparent à des
actes terroristes par des méthodes qui
sont particulières qui sont celles de la
surveillance du territoire du
contre-espionnage et de la police et les
gens font du mieux qu'ils peuvent voilà
je suis persuadé qu'ils font du mieux
qu'il peut et moi tout ce qui traite les
actes terroristes et les terroristes sur
le café dur sur le comptoir du café du
commerce
me désole parce que c'est un problème
qui est d'une pub parce qu'à l'assemblée
on voit que ça vous avez l'extrême
droite où la droite qui se lève en
disant
vous êtes c'est ça capable vous appelle
et vas-y fais-le vas-y tu poses des
affaires tu t'en bouche dans la police
et tu demandes à servir ou dans le
contre espionnage va le faire puisque tu
sais mieux que tout le monde comment il
faut faire vous croyez quoi que les
services qui sont au boulot ça pas leur
métier alors ils pourraient demander des
moyens de plus des jantes plus que terra
et les gadgets électroniques si vous
voulez vraiment mon avis ça me
qu'est ce que vous allez faire espionner
tout quartier le font déjà vous le savez
qu'ils le font ils installent des trucs
qu'ils écoutent tout le monde mais si
kate chuter la machine trie les mots et
bla bla bla bla bla bla bon peut-être
que ça une rentabilité permettez moi
d'en douter dans ce type de lutte ce qui
compte c'est les moyens humains qu'on
déploie
la capacité qu'ont à combattre en
d'abord en parlant les langues
concernées
dans les arabes n'ont hélas pour moi une
perle parler ma grand-mère le parler
mais pas moi moi je parle l'espagnol
parce qu'à tanger quand on était gosses
c'était le national ou r on parlait tous
espagnols l'ema rocard les français les
cycles les avez toute l'épopée clip de
la terre était là pour ça que moi ces
histoires de j'ai toujours eu du mal à
comprendre de court par les cantons
parler de racisme de bons pardon ça
peut-être pas tant de sujets m'enfin moi
j'ai il ça m'a jamais parlé
ce qui m'inquiète c'est comme tout le
monde est pareil
ah bah écoutez il faut de tout pour
faire un monde à clarens
on passe un autre schéma ce que leur
tournoi il est 9h à 19h 20h30 oui 2h40
je tiens le coup d'accord
et ont maintenant la maison monsieur je
vous ferai un beau de dispense y a pas
que moi à mon avis
juan branco crépuscule le hérissé les
gilet jaune on fait quoi l'oligarchie
qui aimait grand c'est votre truc
d'autres techniques d'intervention de
consiste à mettre des mots un derrière
l'oreille sur surtout après deux heures
avec jean luc mélenchon s'est fait
coiffer casse
les noms nous considèrent les gêner
jaune comme le canari dans la mine de la
mondialisation c'est elle qui sont en
train de scier pas mal comme un hommage
merci
on l'est on les voit ils sentent le coup
de grisou ils sont en train de crever il
ya plus rien dans le frigo ils sont
vraiment le couteau sous la gorge on a
une élite qui est dans le déni qui est
dans le
killer jette l'opprobe à la voix de
l'âme en seconde
on va faire quoi et que ça reste là
d'abord les dégâts sont considérables
parce que
une société s'habille quand même avec un
minimum de consentement à des règles
communes est bon il est clair qu'au bout
de 25 semaines la perception que des
masses de gens ont de la police de la
justice des médias c'est incroyablement
dégradé
et je me permets de dire que ce n'est
pas une bonne chose que les élites ou
supposé tel ce soit comporter de cette
manière là parce que cracher comme ça
leur venin sur la masse des gens d'abord
s'est en fait nouveau en france avant
les types de droite nous parlait pas
comme ça
jamais un chirac aurait dit dans les
gares en bois des gens qui ne sont rien
salut je pense à lui serait même pas
venu à l'esprit pourtant il était de
droite de même giscard n'aurait pas fait
ça qui était dans sa commencé avec
hollande et les 100 dons et là vous avez
une espèce de caste
qui s'est constituée qui crache son
venin son mépris et les gens voient qui
sont méprisés et ça crée une ambiance
qui est abominable parce que
je vais peut-être choquer les plus
révolutionnaires de mes amis mais une
société s'est aussi fait de capacité de
compromis mais pour qui est compromis il
faut que tout le monde ait l'impression
que tout le monde fait un effort si les
gens ont l'impression que seulement les
enfants font des efforts et que les
autres n'ont rien à [__] leur crache à
la figure alors là bon c'est la fin des
haricots un jour je prends un exemple
exotique pour illustrer mon propos je me
trouve à san paolo je crois vous à riom
peu importe on bien un truc bilan
carbone ça va ouais ouais bah oui j'ai
quand même brillé j'ai un mea culpa et
c'est à cela gênait un peu mais bref
j'ai voyagé j'ai appris des choses et je
voyais passer les hélicoptères d'une
tour à l'autre et bon
d'accord plat alors je dis un copain bas
les riches
ils passent par les toits pour blaguer
enfin vous voyez comme on est et vous en
êtes débarrassé
et que pas me dit c'est une catastrophe
parce que maintenant ils en n'ont
absolument plus rien à [__] de ce qui
se passe en bas donc les routes les
transports en commun c'est plus leurs
problèmes ça rentre plus dans leur tête
ils n'arrivent pas à comprendre qu'on a
un problème alors on pourrait répondre
par la formule révolutionnaire
débarrassons-nous du capitalisme
évidemment j'en suis d'accord faisons le
découper mais dans l'intervalle il faut
quand même que l'on fasse société quoi
c'est pas possible que les importants se
croit si important surtout comme c'est
du journalisme peut un peu rigoler
d'accord ils sont bien payés trente
mille euros par mois pour la 25 milles
pour ces grosses paye mes vingt dieux
faut quand même qu'ils comprennent que
ils peuvent pas traiter les gens comme
ça avec mépris et ainsi de suite donc
tout ça est pas bon la société française
s'est disloqué
on rattrapera ça si on est capable
d'avoir en commun des grands projets des
lignes d'horizon entre ça que la
transition écologique qui fait jaillir
une conscience collective comme jamais
il ya eu avant depuis deux ou trois
décennies il n'y avait pas une
conscience collective iscom maintenant
même finir par comprendre que même l'air
allait y passer
donc les gens comprennent qu'il ya un
intérêt général humains ils sont ils ont
envie de bien faire donc je pense que on
a des points d'appui mais ça peut être
que comme ça si le point d'appui c'est
de dire écoutez maintenant que chacun
jouissent dans son coin et puis s'occupe
pas des voisins bon on connaît le
résultat la société finira de se
disloquer donc vous avez raison de dire
c'est une bonne image cool que dire que
le gilet jaune c'est le canari dans la
mine avant le coup de grisou mais les
canaris n'ont jamais empêché le coup de
grisou lent ils ont alerté donc cela
alerte les puissants se sont dit on en a
rien à fiche à commencer par le
président de la république a joué le
pourrissement il s'est dit finiront par
se fatiguer il s'attire pas le mal s'est
propagée dans la société cet homme ne
comprend pas ce qu'une crise politique
qui en a jamais vu une société c'est pas
une entreprise lui il qu'en dit la
start-up france il a tout dit sur sa
vision du monde nous sommes 65 millions
de tête dure depuis deux mille ans que
ça dure et et lui croit qu'avec ses
petites mains il va les convaincre
qu'ils font 25 semaines de combats pour
supprimer l'ena si mauvaise plaisanterie
il comprend pas dans quel monde ils et
je parle même pas de revenus de partage
des richesses parce que bien sûr cette
question est posée mais la dignité bon
sens qui comprend ça il faut qu'il le
comprenne enfin il sautera sinon on
trois autres petits trucs l'union des
gauches sais c'est pas un peu de boue
shit atomique
le psc 5%
benoît hamon
connaissent et benoît hamon
l'union des gauches on fait quoi il
reste plus que pas grand chose là
d'abord commencer par définir le moche
pas ça va être intéressant
moi j'ai dit écoutez les cesmo en
jachère parce que les socialistes l'ont
dévastée c'est une terre ils ont
tellement tellement pris tellement pris
tellement prison il puisé savent plus
rien dire il ya plein de gens pour qui
ça veut dire quelque chose dans les
anciennes générations qui se rappelle de
ses luttes mais discutait avec un jeune
qui a entre 20 et 30 ans le ps pour lui
ça ramassis de bons à rien et de
menteurs ray le parti le parti
communiste un petit parti n'ont jamais
connu grand moi j'ai connu le parti
communiste à 20% mais sites étaient
financés par l'indh en grèce non non non
il y avait non non non non le communisme
en france c'est pas un produit
d'importation
c'est quelque chose qui est qui a des
racines profondes dans la culture
française et dans l'histoire de france
non non c'est pas un produit
d'importation mais il était lié à des
conditions d'existence matérielle et
sociale particulière une classe ouvrière
concentré très éduquée une un
tempérament révolutionnaire cultiver
d'une génération à l'autre
bon tout ça a disparu et maintenant il
s'agit de construire de reconstruire
mais pas en pleurnichant et 11 ans la
nostalgie m'enfin moi quand on parle du
nom des gauches
je veux bien mais d'abord de qui on
parle vous allez me dire d'aller vous
parlez que ps qui me traitent de rouge
brands hatch et pas quoi et qui
s'apprête à voter comme speed the
candidate c'est à dire le président de
la commission européenne un néerlandais
qui si vous le mettriez
aux républicains il serait dans l'ailé
droite des républicains
et c'est pour ça qu'ils vont voter bon
vous vous demandez les verts ils ont dit
eux mêmes qu'ils ont rien à voir avec
cette histoire là donc il faut tout
recommencer à zéro avec ce qu'ils
veulent et donc c'est pour ça que moi
j'ai parlé de fédérations de populaire
après tout comment comment on fait nos
anciens sont partis de rien ils ont
construit bas allons-y on va construire
j'ai écouté j'ai quand même fait 7
millions de voix l'élection
présidentielle c'est possible non alors
on dit bah vous les retrouvez pas
maintenant bas ne retrouve pas parce que
ils veulent pas aller voter qu'est-ce
que qu'est-ce que je peux faire à part
continuer la lutte 1 c'est tout ce que
je peux faire sinon j'abandonne et
monsieur macron à gagner ou alors madame
le pen savoir qui encore la peste le
choléra si je vous dis maastricht c'est
le contrepoids politique à la libre
circulation des biens et des
marchandises cette phrase vous inspire
quoi
on l'a cru et moi le premier parce que
j'étais pas trop exigeants à l'époque et
je me suis trompé j'ai toujours dit et
je rappelle pas ce que vous leur fait
sempiternel mans à toutes les élections
que quand en 2005 est arrivé le traité
constitutionnel il contenait tous les
autres traités dedans et j'ai voté non
je rappelle que j'ai voté contre l'euro
j'ai voté contre la banque centrale
européenne et j'ai voté non à maastricht
euh pardon à eau traitée au traité
constitutionnel européen donc j'estime
que j'ai fait preuve d'une capacité
d'autocritique active et concrète que
d'autres n'ont pas eu
bon il va falloir revenir quand même
parce qu'il ya vraiment des sujets qu'on
a pas eu le temps de traiter c'est c'est
les partenariats public-privé la
privatisation n'a pas fait
on n'a pas fait le revenu universel de
quoi le revenu universel
on n'a pas fait le contre les
institutions n'a pas fait le nom on n'a
pas fait le contrôle des institutions
n'a pas fait a pas fait tout ça très
dommage parce que c'est la grosse
question centrale évidemment me dit
toujours oui c'est abstrait personne n'y
comprend rien ça suffit prendre les gens
pour des imbéciles
les gens parfaitement compris la nature
politique de la crise c'est pour ça
qu'ils sont passés de abba la surtaxe
sur le carburant au référendum
d'initiative citoyenne ils ont compris
que c'était politique comment on pouvait
avoir des institutions stables et en
même temps une capacité d'intervention
populaire c'est pour ça que je plaide
pour une sixième république parce que je
crois que c'est aux gens eux mêmes si
vous voulez quand on fait une
constituante le peuple se constitue la
nation se constitue donc eh bien voilà
allez faisons une constituante pour
redéfinit la règle du jeu
la règle du jeu elle a été définie en
1958 par un vote des français et 24
réforme ensuite on l'appuie demander son
avis une fois ou deux je crois pour le
lections suffrage universel bon la
france a tellement changé elle est
devenue urbaine aller beaucoup plus
mélangées socialement il ya eu des
vagues migration comme monter pour à
nouveau faire une une nation en commun
voilà en dessaisissant la règle du jeu
comme on a fait la première fois faut
pas avoir peur du changement ils sont
tous là se gargariser la vème république
il garantit la stabilité de nos
institutions ah oui la stabilité voyez
vous ça on est passé du septennat au
quinquennat on est passé dans tous les
domaines à des changements qui ont
absolument modifié de fond en comble la
vème république en fond cette pauvre
chose pour plantes qu'on a aujourd'hui
sous les yeux avec un pouvoir concentrer
sur un type qui peut devenir fou en
cours de route comme ça s'est déjà
produit ou est nul et on est obligé de
ne rien faire on ne peut pas corriger la
trajectoire c'est ça qui est important
et en plus quand on me dit la stabilité
des institutions mais regardez prenez
l'exemple de la période sarkozy hollande
et fait la moyenne de combien de temps
dure un ministre des finances
d'accord à peine un an alors ça va la
stabilité et tout le reste parce que
évidemment et comme d'habitude pour
faciliter le débat il ya la gloire et la
joie et le pur bonheur avec la vème
république telle qu'elle est ou
l'abomination la catastrophe et
l'anarchie si on écoute mélenchon
évidemment peut-être qu'il ya moyen de
trouver là encore un entre deux mois en
tout cas voilà c'est ça que je dis et je
pense que la question politique centrale
la vie des peuples aient fait ça
on arrive à la fin il va falloir nous
deux il va falloir nous donner trois
livres à dire ah bon et un conseil pour
les jeunes générations
jeudi nadine altérables qui va rester le
plus facile c'est pour les jeunes
générations n'en fait qu'à votre tête
et la plupart des choses impossibles qui
ont été réalisés c'est parce que les
gens n'étaient pas au courant qu'elle
était impossible sa selle ça doit rester
la règle
à l'est et les aînés ont pas trop le
soin donné j'ai l'impression dans le
moment en tout cas politique après quoi
des livres à lire 3
j'ai tellement tu remplis ma vie que
c'est pas juste de faire ça en 5 1
bon allez on peut déjà dire
non plus de matérialisme historique
alors vous allez allez acheter le
bouquin qui s'appelle socialisme
scientifique socialisme utopique faisant
lever le topic se sert à rien c'est les
bastons de l'époque
socialisme scientifique vous permet de
connaître le matérialisme historique le
point de départ un
bon voilà je ne donnerai pas d'autres
deux marques 6 parce qu'après je vais me
lancer dans des polémiques avec tout ça
après
le vieil homme et la mer
morbihan de dizaines à l'esprit
et ceux
qui veulent méditer sur l'incertitude du
monde johann saher l'ancêtre
un châssis bien çà çà çà ou
percuté bon après
moi j'étais baudelaire en poésie ans
donc on peut toujours recommandé les
fleurs du mal
ce serait pas forcément mon meilleur
choix
après toutes ces choses
on a parlé science fiction tout à
l'heure
allez
pour que pour que vous voyez l'origine
de l'hologramme
fondation et empire des imf
encore un truc de prétention absolue
parce que la psychohistoire prétendait
prévoir les développements de l'histoire
où il se passe un événement qui n'était
pas prévu tout se casse la figure c'est
intéressant le déterminisme sera jamais
autre chose que probabiliste après bon
alors j'ai dit à mon livre de poésie en
ligne de science fiction un livre sur le
matérialisme historique moi je
recommande une petite biographie
historique souvent mais je l'offre à mes
collaborateurs
c'est la biographie de lyons par paul
murray kendall
qui se barrent les gens le voient pas
l'interviewer se marre parce que c'est
le triomphe de l'intelligence
face à un type extrêmement agitée
enfin bon voulurent et le livre si ça
vous intéresse mais ça se lit bien ça
ceux qui comme eux
comme un roman mais après qu'est ce
qu'il vous dise moi allez faites un
effort et vous pouvez lire un peu de
rose pas moins 93 un
bon os pieter hugo
allez on va mauvaise recommandation d'un
petit peu de michelet
pourtant il est anti robespierre ça me
plaît pas trop mais bon michelet sait si
vous voulez je peux donc vous intéresser
à l'histoire de france bon il ya mille
grand historien enfin mais moi je
recommande michelez parce que on y
rentre comme dans un roman donc ça
accroche la tension 1
parce qu'un livre si vous tombe des
mains c'est pas la peine de forcer ça
sert à rien ça ça rentrera pas si le lit
vous tombez main vous laisser tomber et
puis c'est tout j'en prenais un autre
vous avez lu 1984
ouais nan mais attends c'est totalement
déprimant alors c'est instructif c'est
le livre d'orwell 1
1984 alors on est en ce moment en train
de le vivre alors oui il a raison musée
ça tient la ferme des animaux de la
ferme des animaux
où est la ferme des animaux oui oui
c'est un truc qu'on tient bureaucratie
mais l'orage en est d'autres vous
proposer si vous aimez ça les bouquins
antibureaucratique mais qu'il faut un
peu rire boulgakov corps de chien c'est
une histoire marrante ils ont décidé
c'est un chien ont réussi à le
transformer en homme alors est ce vrai
le lien est bon le problème c'est que le
gars y'a pas moyen de lui faire faire
quoi que ce soit et qu'il serait on sait
pas quoi l'utiliser puisqu'il y bon à
rien et à la fin quand même ils ont
trouvé une utilité autres métiers où il
est vachement content
il travaille à la fourrière et la trappe
les chats bon c'est pour la note
humoristique mais bon après quoi a dit
mans un autre
en
sursis sur quoi eh ben je sais pas moi
en vous avez lu labo un beau morceau de
littérature qu'est ce que vous me
suggéra auriez je vous donne mon avis
les furtifs
desmazes où
la horde ça vous tente pas olonne
non non non
allez bon on va faire la littérature
américaine
il ya peut-être des littéraires qui me
regardent la nation c'est une certitude
il doit sûrement y en avoir eh ben je
vous mon moteur américain crs keane
coldwell
la route du tabac parce que par rapport
à la narration française il n'y a aucune
intériorité il décrit de l'extérieur
y'a que moi que ça fait rire en la route
du tabac les gens trouvent ça sinistre
et moi le récit de ces crétins
mais tellement plein d'humanité
tellement des armées est absolument
complètement désarmé devant la vie qui
les dépasse ils sont dans une crise
économique se trouve ça
fort j'ai plus aimé par exemple dit
stenbeck peu j'aime beaucoup aussi un ou
même jack london qui était notre
notre repère le town faire tout ça les
gens ils connaissent croc blanc parce
qu'il donne sa lire à leurs gosses
mais jack london c'est un auteur
socialiste avait lui vous avez lu
houellebecq way
joker
non attends moi je vis pour le bonheur
d'accord je lis pas pour me mettre un
sac de sang sur la tête plein de glaire
tu vois c'est vrai quoi pour ça il ya
d'autres occupations non je sais que je
parle mal là il faut mais je dis ce que
je pense voilà moi j'ai ça va quoi j'en
ai lu deux j'en pouvais plus c'est comme
amélie nothomb
non matin en s'emparant
bon alors mais non maintenant il ya des
trucs stupeur et tremblements ce très
bien la guerre de chine parfait mais
après ça commençait à se traîner un j'ai
trouvé que bon
pour tanger j'admirais cette femme et le
niveau d des choses qu'elle disait pour
provoquer j'ai trouvé ça admirable mais
maintenant je suis obligé de dire
écoutez madame à la rentrée je n'achète
plus votre livre parce que ça va me
déprimer et moi j'ai besoin des choses
un peu
on peureuse à
vous arrivez à la fin
j'en ai plein de quoi du monde du moins
très messieurs
merci d'avoir redoré votre temps rôle
d'être venu je
sais pas moi que ça va coûter plus cher
c'est à vous parce qu'il faut payer tout
le monde ainsi tout le monde est payé et
j'ai combien tout milliers de syndiqués
j'espère les gars encore
merci d'être venus merci de m'avoir
écouté parler si l'on demande c'est un
désastre pour moi parce que j'ai dû dire
au tas de choses qui vont me revenir
dans la figure ça va c'était très gentil
c'est politiquement correct on comptait
vous attaquer au vitriol et à la batte
de base-ball mais on a laissé venir
c'était pas mal on vous rappellera pour
vous vouliez m'attaquer à la batte de
baseball comme si c'était dans vos
moyens
bon allez à table jean luc mélenchon
merci merci à vous monsieur
[Musique]